in a viral video
dr senator rand paul called on americans
to resist the cdc's anti-science mask
mandates this resulted in him trending
on twitter with like hundreds of
thousands of tweets and of course a well
turned into a propaganda war i suppose
with people saying that he was either
pushing uh pushing misinformation or
peddling other you know garbage nonsense
and so there's a question around whether
or not rand paul should be listened to
considering we're looking at the
expansion of mass mandates and more
importantly even nbc has written that
vaccine mandates could actually hurt the
economy because
people are going to choose not to take
jobs there there are companies that are
doing mass mandates that are companies
doing vaccine mandates and there's a lot
of people saying you know what i'm not
going to do that so then they don't get
jobs and then these companies can't hire
and now we have something really
fascinating happening
we have 10.1 million job openings
we have more jobs available than people
available to work at this point which
they say is supposed to be indicative of
some great economic boom but in fact
we're coming off of a massive economic
recession so this has people quite
worried companies are trying to hire
nobody is available to work we'll see
what that leads to but uh we're gonna
have a fun conversation because we are
being joined by the editor-in-chief of
the post millennial libby evans hello
you wanna introduce yourself i'm libby
emmons i'm the editor-in-chief of
post-millennial i'm really glad to be
here tonight
and uh
and where do you live
you're gonna kill me on this one
i'm ready for it i live in brooklyn new
york oh man oh no so now if you wanna
you know go to go to the bodega and get
a sandwich they make you you you got to
get like a full physical and then yes
that's right you get strip searched yeah
that's what's going on no but it uh but
we'll definitely it'll be interesting to
talk about your experience in new york
and what's going on especially in light
of you know what randa is saying and
everything so yeah it's interesting yeah
we got ian doctor senator
senator
dr senator are they really like
not letting people into bodegas without
getting vaccines uh
bill de blasio the illustrious mayor of
new york city
put in place this requirement that you
have to show your vaccine card or this
excelsior pass that governor andrew
cuomo created which has
plenty of problems but the requirement
goes into effect i believe september
13th
so there's a very limited period of time
in order to still enjoy the delights of
the big house
you mean a limited amount of time to
escape from new york well there's that
too yeah great movie by the way
who was it who uh played kurt russell
that's my jam well you still have about
a month and a half so a little bit about
a month so you know good luck it can be
for my birthday it'll be my birthday
present there you go we got uh we got
lydia pushing back i'm here in the
corner pushing buttons i'm delighted to
have libby as always enjoy her input and
really looking forward to hear what
she's saying about what's going on in
her his her city of new york city and
and i'll also add too hollywood stars
are fleeing for austin so to all of the
people we know who are like you got to
go to austin i'm like i said this is
going to happen because they're going to
bring everyone with them so i'm
certainly we were looking at texas we're
like maybe we should go to texas and
then i was like no i don't want to go to
texas and i'm glad i didn't but before
we get started head over to timcast.com
become a member and you'll get access to
exclusive members-only segments from the
team cast irl podcast as well as an
advertisement free experience you'll be
supporting our fierce and independent
journalists as well as our new shows i
got the rough cut on the new uh mystery
show but we're getting ready for the
branding and the launch it's gonna be a
whole lot of fun so again go to
teamcast.com support our work but don't
forget to like this video subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends give us a good podcast review
and uh share the show if you really like
it let's read this first story you may
have seen the viral clip senator rand
paul i'm sorry dr senator rand paul
urges people to defy covet mandates they
can't arrest all of us that's a bold
statement he says quote
it's time for us to resist
they can't arrest all of us they can't
keep all of your kids home from school
we don't have to accept the mandates
lockdowns and harmful policies of the
petty tyrants and bureaucrats we can
simply say no not again paul also
threatened to hold up every bill with
two amendments if any school system
tries to keep kids out of the classroom
this fall one to defund them and another
to allow parents the choice of where
their money goes for their child's
education
that should be law anyway we should have
school choice but he says uh there's a
quote
children are falling behind in school
and are being harmed physically and
physiol and psychologically by the
tactics that you have used to keep them
from the classroom during the last year
we won't allow it again
now of course there's already a bunch of
people who are uh claiming that he's
telling people to outright defy the cdc
in general which was the funniest thing
i saw from that they were like rand paul
says to uh to defy the cdc and i'm like
he specifically said the restrictions
that he called anti-science i don't
think he said the entirety of the cdc
and that distinction is kind of
important because the cdc does more than
just talk about coven mind you they talk
about a lot of things but um
man what should people do i don't know
you live in uh the the authoritarian
hellscape what do you think i do live in
the authoritarian hellscape and i gotta
be honest with you i thought we had a
shot you know i thought things were not
going to quite get this bad um a lot of
people in new york city are vaccinated i
think we have some rather high
percentage of new yorkers who are
vaccinated there are people who still
don't want to get vaccinated
it's not because
they haven't had access to it so at this
point they are making their grown-up
choice
to
undergo medical treatment or not
for some reason
this is not good enough for
the leftist government de blasio has
always been a disaster he's been a
disaster since the moment he was elected
he is not an intelligent man he is not a
good elected leader
he has absolutely no principles
whatsoever there's nothing worthwhile
about him at all
uh but i did not think that he would
literally throw the entire city under
the bus just in order to uh you know
satisfy this this weird idea that he has
so where everybody needs to just do what
he says so yeah so there's this idea
this vaccine passport
cuomo created an excel they actually
call it the excelsior pass you can
download it on your phone it will track
your kova test results it will track
your covet vaccine you can show it
and additionally part of the idea with
the excelsior pass is that if you show
it to get into a sporting event or what
have you
you also have to show supposedly your id
this is what it says on the new york
state website so that they can prove
that it's actually your past so now in
order to
move about freely in the city where you
live you have to show your papers at
various places
yeah that's what it says on the website
i don't know i haven't used it i won't
obviously i'm never going to download
something so the government can track me
on my phone i mean we're probably
already tracked whatever but i'm not
going to voluntarily do that
this is interesting because it's
it enters the public sphere as like oh
but it's about vet you got your vaccine
already what's the big deal and you need
your id and then you need your id and
then
what's next that's right right what's
next it's also racist of course well
it's racist for two reasons asking for
id is racist democrats said so voting
and it is true in new york and
especially many of the places the black
community is the least least likely to
be vaccinated among racial demographics
yeah so that was something i was
thinking about too because you know de
blasio's paid lip service to the black
community for a long time um
even last year when we had all the blm
protests and then you had the i forget
what they were called but they were like
the covet tracker people right they like
test and trace yeah so new york had this
like whole test and trace core and if
you tested positive for covid um i don't
know if they still do but they would
call you
um oh yeah and track you down and de
blasio and cuomo one of the things that
they agreed on during the pandemic was
that you are not allowed to ask someone
if they have been to a protest when you
are doing a like track and trace thing
for covid
everything's a protest from now on so
you're allowed to protest without having
and and so then they said like you know
then all these reports came out that
said blm protests weren't super super
spreader events you literally weren't
allowed to ask people if they'd been to
a protest yeah once they were tracked
with coved you weren't allowed to ask
them so there's actually no way of
knowing whether or not they were super
spread out or events or not i i have a
question for you what percentage of
residents of new york city do you think
are vaccinated
i think it's something like 60.
it is 55.6 there you go so close yeah
it's it's that's that's half it's
absolutely plenty of an amount i think i
think we're gonna see more exodus from
new york city i think so too um there
were already like 400 000 really rich
families that left during the pandemic
the new york city school system started
out
in 2020 with 1.1 million
public school students a nice
healthy number robust school system
and i think we're down
we're in like the eight hundred
thousands area now whoa
is this the u.s just being crushed like
on purpose
being what crushed is the us being
crushed on purpose yeah
like
by some other authoritative type of
situation well maybe maybe not
necessarily on purpose might go too far
but the policies being put in place are
just destroying the country
yeah i think they are destroying the
country i think we have a real ethos
problem we've heard joe biden say over
and over again uh that his job is to
keep americans safe
the the president's job is not to keep
americans safe the president's job is to
you know run the country the way that
his constituents say
and commander in chief of the armed
forces to technically do that and like
you know keep the country safe perhaps
but not individuals and it's not his job
to do anything other than to protect our
rights and
that's not what's going on our rights
are not being protected when we're being
treated as though we can't make
decisions about our own medical care
yeah it feels like everything being put
into place and i
probably said this 50 million times by
now is just literally destroying the
economy and yeah you have to ask i i
what is if if we're doing the same thing
we did last time and it didn't work last
time why are we doing the same thing
again
like they're they're putting in policies
that according to nbc news are going to
hurt the job uh the job recitation right
growth and they're putting in they're
putting into place policies that will
basically just drive people out of new
york and we did hear bill de blasio say
he wanted to convert the abandoned
buildings into public housing right so
maybe insofar as it goes to like de
blasio
on purpose isn't that far i think he
does want to completely destroy the city
i don't think he has any vision at all
or any understanding of what it is that
new york is really about the other issue
too is a matter of enforcement so
we've seen i think we were looking at
videos earlier
in france
you see police going around to the
restaurants being like oh let me see
your
let me see your documentation that
permits you to be outside of your home
uh make sure you've what are you going
to do in new york is they're going are
they going yes are the police going to
be asked to do this yeah because here's
another [ __ ] here's an issue with that
here's an issue with that first of all
if the police aren't asked to do it now
you're asking just your basic guy at the
bodega to start demanding things of
patrons
i don't know about you guys i get really
testy when people ask me for stuff that
they're not entitled to about my person
right i was telling you guys earlier
about an incident in philadelphia we
don't need to get into but
um but
if it's not
you're just basic mcdonald's employee
who gets to demand these things of you
your basic middle manager who then drunk
on power is going to freak out at you
and start calling you names
if the new york city police department
is asked to do this will they do it you
think they will do it oh absolutely i
was talking to
some guys at the nypd that i met at um
some black trans rights lives matter
protests over the summer that were
actually rather amusing and uh
i was talking to a guy who said that the
nypd in fact declined to enforce social
distancing mandates
what happened was
it was early on it was like may 2020
and they were being asked to enforce
social distancing they were going out
into the communities where there was the
most coveted most active coveted so what
were these communities these were mostly
minority communities so they're
wandering around like
fort greene or whatever you know like
crown heights
wandering around like um bed stuy
looking for black people and latino
people on their stoop having barbecues
right and then telling them to go inside
so the guys i was talking to and the
force they were like that was a really
super bad look that we were like
breaking up you know here we are we're
told to
be less enforcing
of things in these communities we had
done stop and frisk whatever else they
pulled back on that and now they're
supposed to tell them to all go inside
so they refused they declined to enforce
that they declined to enforce the mask
thing if you go around if you're on the
ny um
new york city subway system and you
happen to spot a police officer
which is
not super frequent these days but if you
haven't spot them they're not wearing
masks lots of other people are wing
masks the nypd declined to enforce this
stuff in fact do you i don't know if you
guys remember there was a bar in staten
island yeah that was like very vocally
opposed so it was the state police that
were enforcing that stuff because that's
who cuomo had control over well then the
state police are going to come in and do
it do you think that oh yeah the state
police would end up with that this is
the normal thing they do they bring in
outside cops because you know if you're
a cop in new york
you're worried that
if the nypd steps on toes of the locals
then you're not going to be able to go
to restaurants you're not going to be
able to like people throwing stuff at
you so
it happened in uh with attila's gym
that's right new jersey the local cops
from that town showed up and said have a
nice day everybody and left right so
they brought in outside cops who came in
and said screw you with a smile on their
face and put the boot down you know yeah
i wonder how that would go down um
hopefully nobody ever has to find out
what a disaster is what a total
nightmare they did it with the bar they
shut it down there was a bar in staten
island and the guy was he wasn't even
selling anything he was like it's just
i'll give it away for free i guess and
then the state police came and
stood in front of the building
they i think they arrested the guy right
yeah they arrested him multiple times
and there was literally a bar like a
block and a half away that was allowed
to operate and he wasn't because they
did like zones they did these stupid
zones
yeah there was also as though these
zones are impossible my son tells me
about this you know we'll go into a
restaurant and then you don't have to
take it before and and he'd be like uh
oh well that's right once we sit down we
can take our masks off because chairs
are covered blockers that's true he's
11. he's 11 and he sees through this
mess
this is the craziest thing i love
there's a meme where it's like uh
they
someone pulls up to a drive-through and
they're being handed a there's a tray
holding the like the wendy's bag and
then the person's like what's this and
they're like it's your food it's like
why is it on a tray and they're like for
covid like why can't you just hand me
the bag because you're trying to reduce
contact it's like you mean to tell me
that you literally handled the meat
handled the bread handled the lettuce
you put it all in the wrapper put it all
in the bag you've touched it all already
and now you've put on a tray that you
won't touch that so you're not so you're
not touching the bag the one last time
if anything you've increased the amount
of contact you made by holding the tray
just give me the food early on at the
post millennial we were running a lot of
stories like that because they were just
so hysterical and there was one with
like a guy at tim hortons pushing out a
coffee on a hockey stick like that
that's really funny oh man you know it's
not helping that's why i'm saying we are
chickens in a chicken coop
that's i guess yeah some of the chickens
are like hey something's not right the
when you guys earlier talk about state
police coming in it made me think of the
shays rebellion uh are you familiar with
this rebellion right after the they fed
the uh the confederate basically after
the united states did the uh what is
that 13 colonies yeah
of independence they had like an
original document that they were using
articles
and the states had too much control and
their their own police wouldn't enforce
like the farmers rebellion wanted the
courts shut down the police were like no
let them we these are our friends we're
not going to stop them so they had to
call in the the state police
and then they were like this is too
dangerous to give so much power locally
we need to federalize and in a way
they're right because they were able to
organize taxes and military but
you know the danger of that is now you
can send in the feds everything's broken
and breaking and i love it when uh you
know we pulled up the polls last week uh
you probably won't be surprised by this
libya the majority of democrat voters
believe the economy is fairly good
the majority of independent and
republican voters think the economy is
either very bad or fairly bad yeah what
about what's happening has these
democrats being like this is fine but
they're not paying any attention there
you go you know they're just not looking
at it these are the people who are in
their homes they've barely left these
are the double maskers you know who
watch rachel maddow that's true and are
probably still scrubbing their
groceries for goodness sake it's a it's
insane the real issue too i mean there's
so many real issues but what happens
when it doesn't work you know when
people still don't get vaccinated wait
wait wait wait wait
it
whatever we did the past year it didn't
work cases are surging against the thing
they're talking there's talks about
lockdowns maybe we won't lock down but
we got to wear masks again
it's still not going to work
so how much are we going to give away
and my favorite argument too is the
people who are like you know we've given
up our rights in the past so what are
you complaining about now it's really
it's really not that big a deal and it's
like well maybe we should have not
resistance is futile rights in the past
as well maybe we should not have
capitulated to these authoritarian
ideologies well previously um i got out
of the cities
you did get out of the city you didn't
i didn't nope i
i did not so well so this is interesting
though because
there's two things i want to hit at
first we we briefly mentioned a little
bit of the new york stuff but what i've
been saying for the past couple of
months is that it's like you're in a
house and the garage starts on fire and
you're like i'm in the living room who
cares and i'm like
yeah okay but the other issue is more
importantly
you could argue if i'm sitting in my
living room and the garage catches fire
i can go put the fire out the problem is
you've got other people in your house
holding you back saying there's no fire
stop
and that's the new york voter base
that should be a meme that should be
that dog meme you know the dog is trying
to put the fire out this is fun that
should be part of it yeah my uh
look i love new york city i've always
loved new york city i always wanted to
live there my whole life my great
grandparents came from italy to new york
city when i went like in 1911 or
something like that my grandparents were
born in little italy my mom was born in
brooklyn
um i was born in jersey because my
parents were in law school there my son
was born in brooklyn
i love new york city new york city is
like
uh it
these kinds of restrictions and rules
will make new york city not what it is
when i go out recently right so
um washington square parks downtown and
we've written about this also post
millennial there's been like a lot of
um police crackdowns at washington
square park i was down there one night
over what
you know they just don't like the kids
they don't want the kids having fun is
the way i see it i talk to some
residents and people who live in
greenwich village which used to be like
a super artsy neighborhood and is now
basically just nyu's campus and so it's
like a lot of rich professors
um in their
nyu housing or whatever and they don't
like having people in the park past
midnight so the cops can bound they
close the park after midnight they try
and kick everybody out and when you walk
through washington square park these
days at night
it's kind of great it's kind of like it
was in the 90s right like there's a lot
of kids
making out making a mess getting high
like screwing around you know like
it reminds me of my misspent youth which
i like then the cops come in and shut it
down but
that kind of new york um
and also in the east side on the lower
east side people are always out they're
unmasking they're all you know they're
like having a good time
none of that can last with these kind of
restrictions none of that can
continue the art scene can't continue
with that and arts culture also has been
so incredibly co-opted by
authoritarianism at this point you know
it's propaganda they just like do
exactly what they're told they create
the kind of work that they're told
yeah that's the people uh in new york
and how they vote i mean it's yes it is
i i'm i'm continually impressed by the
cognitive dissonance of
the tv says x one day and then why the
next day but they're both consistent i
just love these memes that are going
around where it's like these blue check
people tweeting things like you know
during trump why would anyone trust the
federal government and then there's one
guy and he's literally saying give me
the booster every single day
now they love it now they love the
federal government it's insane so yeah
so
so they're they're voting the uh how do
you how do you save us this is a thing
look a lot of people are like don't
leave the cities tim stay and fight and
i'm like dude new york's like 20
conservative and i don't even i'm not
even saying conservatives have all the
like have the right answer it's just the
only alternative and there's nothing
there's nothing and and there aren't any
options right i mean i'm
i'm a registered democrat in new york so
that i can vote in the primary because
other like who cares about the mayoral
primary on the on the republican ticket
it just doesn't matter
uh eric adams was on the ticket and it
was actually fascinating to see how many
like to see that eric adams won that
primary he was the i mean he's
democratic party machine so yes he's far
leftist etc but he was the most
conservative one on the ticket and
people were shocked that minorities
voted for eric adams instead of maya
wiley who was like
you know oh progressive and we're like
eating rainbow puke and all of that
stuff but this is this is just
losing it's losing so yeah do i want to
leave cities no i love cities you are
partially right though
um but i did fall in love with dallas
recently
which was amazing i was down there um
covering cpac with post-millennial and i
kind of
loved i
really loved dallas um
so a couple of things one
it was really non-judgmental
so a lot of guns i don't i didn't see a
lot of guns but maybe that's part of it
maybe that just keeps everyone polite
and what would they say in our society
is a polite society you know um but the
people i met were very non-judgmental
very just like open and like hey what's
up i would say like people would say
like oh you know what are you doing here
i'd be like i'm here for work nobody
asked me what i did for a living no one
cared i respect that
um i've lived i've spent my entire life
in the northeast
where
who your family is matters where you
went to school matters what your job is
matters like all of these little things
matter and the only thing that doesn't
really matter is who you are personally
and individually you know all that
matters is like the trappings of who you
are
and in dallas it wasn't like that um
there was this great neighborhood called
deep ellum where i went out drinking
pretty much every night which i really
that was fun but another thing that i
liked too uh
was that it wasn't a big city but it
didn't have these same it didn't feel
like it had these same kind of
constraints oh i mean texas is open
isn't it yeah texas is pretty open i was
in houston last week which was different
than dallas what was the difference
um
houston is a little more
it felt like a little more glam i think
it's also not as walkable dallas was
very walkable city
which i liked like i could walk to all
of the places i wanted to go
um
another thing i liked too though just
you know and maybe it's just because i
spent my whole life in the northeast and
it's changing so quickly into something
that
where i don't feel comfortable where i
where i don't feel like i can be part of
life there like
when i was in texas
i've never spent i've never spent like
any time in the south ever in my life
like i've been to florida
when i was eight i think we went to um
the beach in the carolinas you know yeah
ocean isles nice i don't know like i was
there's a picture of me in a bathing
suit like i don't really know what's
going on uh i remember the condo was
cold that's it so
i've never spent any time in south and
then
it was amazing to have absolutely no
point of reference
like there were no memories anywhere
there were no in new york everywhere i
go like every street i walk down every
corner you know it's like oh i remember
that i remember that i was recently
walking with friends and i realized that
we you know we kept passing theaters
where i'd had work performed and you
know i don't do theater anymore
um but i was like every time i was like
oh crushing a little crushing a little
crushing uh nothing like that
in dallas which also is open and free
and comfortable and people are
non-judgey and
you know maybe
maybe i can i don't know maybe i can
make a new life i'm also i'm really
interested in moving the post-millennial
to a southern state so we've been kind
of talking about that
um i hear tennessee is great tennessee
gotta visit tennessee i would say yeah
tennessee or kentucky or west virginia
so i'm i'm yeah i'm open but what's sort
of
like what i keep marveling at is that
i've never been open to leaving the
northeast in my entire life
like ever and now i'm just like oh my
god
put me in my car and drives out but look
who's being driven out so you mentioned
you know a lot of people who left new
york were like wealthy it was like um
upper class sure lower upper class it's
you know not necessarily people who are
millionaires but well they were able to
keep their apartments
the people who moved no the millionaires
oh right right right exactly they just
went to their other house exactly the
ultra rich were like i'm gonna go stay
in mother's vineyard for a little while
like obama they party with him exactly
exactly but a lot of people were like
we're moving and they had the ability to
move very quickly so they're well off
but not necessarily the ultra rich or
anything like that they're leaving but
you're not ultra rich or anything and
now you're leaving nope yeah so they're
driving away you they're homogenizing
the city the only people who are going
to stay are going to be
die-hard authoritarians who are just
like whatever de blasio says i will do
no matter what and they do or the really
poor
the people who can't leave will now live
under them
yeah and then people are right yeah and
then the new york city public school
system which i watched uh
decades of rebuilding
and so that like you know
my friends who have money were sent who
could afford private school were sending
their kids to public schools
um i sent my child to a public school
after his private school closed uh
i can't afford the private schools in
new york city it's like 45 000 a year
ridiculousness plus they're trash i mean
the that's the other piece is they are
trash um at the end of the school year
this year a couple of my son's teachers
uh i want to say came out to me as
conservative oh wow and they were like
we really like what you've been doing
there's too many people who do that
sorry it's not you know what and they
should just speak up now they're in
teachers unions they were handing me
maya wiley flyers or whatever it was and
they were like we have to hand you this
and i was like i'm not voting for you
know
people do it to me when i was in
portland
i had black block masked anti-walk and
maybe like dude we love your stuff
and then i was like what are they doing
they're serving the machine yes serving
the machine there are people who
well to be fair
there's probably
the people who are talking to me were
like i like that you try to at least you
know give the information but we still
don't like those guys so they can say oh
you're cool you're all right but they're
still zealots and that's and it's still
a problem but when we have tons of
people i can't tell you how many emails
we get where it's like i really wish i
could say something but i can't i'm like
dude then we're screwed we're screwed i
agree with you i get those emails too
from people who you know were in theater
and that i've worked with and they're
like oh i'm still trying to hang out to
my theater career and i'm like cash it
in dude like chuck it start over let's
do something else but and everyone
always responds it's easy to say
you know when you don't have kids
because they're these people have kids
you've got a job that you can move with
that actually you yeah your cultural
positions benefit your career a lot of
people don't have that and i'm still
saying dude look i get it i don't have
kids but i can tell you this i'm worried
about the future for the next generation
because people won't speak up and defend
their kids that's right if you're not
going to defend your children and the
world they live in then you're giving
them trash
so as for uh leaving new york i will say
i say get out of the cities and a lot of
people are like tim
but what about texas and what about
florida i'm like good point miami is
pretty cool the weather is brutal the
weather seems the weather is like it's
like you might as well go live under the
sea it's like humid and raining all the
time but desantis is doing a pretty good
job with the state they're they're
coming out and saying like oh the covey
and all this crazy stuff and i'm like
at this point if people have the the
opportunity to get the vaccines they
don't want to do it i don't know what a
country is supposed to do if you like
you know i guess de blasio forced people
to do it but i digress here's the
problem right here
from the new york post
hollywood stars are fleeing to austin
amid the coven 19 pandemic and i warned
y'all this would happen
when there's that comic of joe rogan and
he's got his little pull pull bag you
know whatever roller bag and he's
walking from california texas and the
bag says liberal politicians have been a
fanny pack by the way and there's it
says liberal policies on it and there's
a cowboy saying like hey hold on there
mister why don't you leave that where
you got it everyone's like yeah but is
joe rogan really going to be bringing
these policies with him he may be fairly
like lefty in a lot of ways but he's
very anti-authoritarian
and he has staff
and he is going to run a business like
with with you know he's got he's got his
comedy uh aspirations he wants to he
wants shows he started a club there you
go gotta hire people so what's gonna
happen the people from the industry in
california are gonna be like well joe
rogan's hiring i guess i'll go out there
and those are rational people they're
not far lefties but they're a little
lefty they'll probably still vote
democrat and then the rest of the
hollywood stars are going to be like did
you hear that elon musk and and and uh
you know and and uh
all of these really fun and amazing
people are moving austin i should go
there too and i've got a bunch of
hollywood celebrities being like
austin's the place to be and guess what
they're going to bring all their staff
and they're going to bring all their
lefty politics that's right because the
because the person who makes 50 000 a
year carrying the the the coattails of
some hollywood celebrity is not going to
be conservative they're going to be like
uh uh to to those according to their
needs or whatever that's what they're
going to be advocating for
so they're all going to come and taxes
is going to help
well maybe i think i i definitely think
so that's the case okay so if that's the
case uh so the new yorkers are flying to
florida we've seen that uh californians
are fleeing to texas that's happening so
where the hell are we supposed to go
west virginia west virginia tennessee
kentucky almost in texas again i mean
tennessee kentucky west virginia i know
louisville is uh
has some interesting stuff going on
where's that louisville yeah louisville
louisville i don't even know i don't
know i don't even know
louisville actually that's in colorado
so yeah let me just pretend i got that
mixed up
nashville here is doing pretty pretty
good right you know yeah you've got uh
daily daily wires out there yeah yeah
see everybody you want to visit it was
it was so reactive for everybody to be
like texas and i'm like that's like a
trope about texas being this like free
and very red state it's like it was
almost 50 50 this past couple past
couple of elections and austin is deep
blue and it's attracting all of the
hipsters it's it's been since south by
southwest as far as i can remember it's
very hipster well austin has been for a
long time what about like maybe eastern
montana
oh oh no no no
montana and wyoming 100 oh yeah wyoming
you want to go live in the middle of
nowhere and rough it and figure it out
for yourself
do it do it you can do that i think
bozeman might be a little blue though
yeah yeah that's why i'm saying eastern
montana yeah i've driven through there
it's awesome it's beautiful you can't
even get cell services
i'm saying look so
we were
we didn't want to move to a place where
we're going to get the influx of
the the progressive faux activist i
don't even think it's fair to call the
hollywood stars leftists that's unfair
to leftists
it is
like if if i can sit here and have a
conversation with an actual communist
who believes in communism and genuinely
believes in communism i can respect them
actually standing up and being honest
these hollywood even though i disagree
with them the hollywood stars they don't
believe in anything
they're just saying they're like
so we're looking at places they're
opportunists absolutely they're like
whatever whatever the the corporations
want me to say so they pay me their
models glorified models they're market
it's marketing they're they're literally
marketing tools for movies and for shows
so of course they're going to side with
corporate america and say whatever they
think will sell more doesn't mean that
they don't know stuff some of them are
probably incredibly educated well sure
james woods
yeah you get you get the he's a little
mean though you know your job is to keep
your mouth shut though so if they are if
they do know what's going on they will
get ostracized if they speak up
to me basically i stop getting called
back when they start my youtube videos
2007. that was rough look we we were
trying to find a place where we can get
away from the cities have space and
you know expand and we were in the
philly area and it was it was nuts it
was one of the worst states for
restrictions and they told us like in
march don't go outside anymore unless
you have no choice they were like don't
walk around with people and we were like
this is crazy that's insane but we look
at texas and i'm like i can see what's
going to happen in texas i can see
what's going to happen with these
hollywood california arizona colorado
they're all going to keep coming in and
then there you go you end up with
hipster blue state now west virginia is
losing people people are because there's
a there there's this phenomenon that's
really fascinating even in red states
urban centers tend to be blue for some
reason
so even in west virginia you have
blue areas
the people who are there
there's an article i was reading in the
ap and they were this woman was like i'm
a teacher and this is horrible the state
is terrible i'm leaving i'm going to
texas
and i was like yes
get out of here west virginia man you've
got a lot of opportunity we were looking
at some small dying towns i was like
wouldn't it be cool if we went to an
area that used to be bustling with life
and it's got buildings and
infrastructure but now it's an
opportunity zone because the industry
left we could save money we could have
available uh resources and internet find
a bunch of towns just like that the
problem no good airports so bringing
people in would be impossible so then we
find this area basically which is the
compromise where we're close enough to
an airport but kind of far away but this
facility is still in maryland so it kind
of sucks but there is that i mean i love
this idea of like revitalizing a dead
town there's a there was like a town in
an entire town in connecticut i think i
saw like a year or so ago
the entire town was for sale wow
um megan mccain talks about this i don't
want to live in connecticut
but megan mccain talks about this on
instagram a lot she's like you know
let's let's create a new place to live
we'll just all go move there and there's
something to that idea of like
just everybody just go to some town and
turn it into a place where you want to
be like all these solar panels on every
roof you don't need a central electric
grid or whatever
you know that could be your town well so
uh we're we're planning this in a
different town
we have this totally we could get like
some light rail going that'd be great
yeah you you think we're joking i'm not
joking
i need a place to live let's
build one no no we've been planning it
for the past couple of weeks nice so we
need um a bigger production facility
this this place we're in right now can
can host a few of the shows we're doing
but we've got so much happening and so
many people that were like okay we need
a another building we need another space
because we we don't have the offices for
this place i love how the media is like
dimboo bought an eight bedroom mansion
it's like yeah we rent out half of it
for production and the other half is
basically a green room essentially where
people are like working plus why can't
you have whatever you want
like have your big house if you want
well sure sure but what i mean is they
try to make it seem like the purpose of
the house is like
we're all we're all just like we have a
theater room and a game room and a
bowling room and it's like well we have
an office in office an office an office
an office a studio studio so we need
another building so we can actually
alleviate some of that pressure so that
you can have the bowling room and the
game room yes actually i mean we do have
a skate park two lanes which is awesome
right yeah i mean boy fair so here's the
plan we were i was looking for these
these places in west virginia where we
would just start building something
because it's it's actually surprisingly
not that expensive if you're building
just like a standard like office unit
kind of building
and uh i we we went to
i forgot where we were going i don't
remember where we were going to the mall
or something and we took the scenic
route and we drove through a bunch of
these small towns in west virginia that
were just
nothing
like they're just little houses and then
i was like a lot of these places are for
sale for cheap they need to work to fix
them up
but why bother
trying to build this massive unit and
get utilities installed and all that
stuff when we could literally buy like
three of these houses for the same price
and then have twice as much space as we
normally would we wouldn't have the
acreage but we'd have a decent amount of
acreage and then we actually just have a
little urban hub like well suburban hub
where we have like that building oh yeah
that's where they do video editing that
building is where they do the game
design and so then you have a little
town inside of a building right i think
that would be epic
that sounds really badass it sounds way
better than going to austin with a bunch
of hollywood celebrities who are just
like vomiting up faux activism and who
have absolutely no principles yeah yeah
and then you're in west virginia which
is the second reddest state in the
country
you know the funny thing is though i'll
come like i'm i'm in all right
bring bring your friends we'll bring the
post millennial to the new town we'll be
like the resident newspaper great yeah
this is the funniest thing though check
it out
i've uh i've long maintained this even
going back to the days of like ron paul
because i don't completely agree with
ron paul's conservative positions in a
lot of ways but i do agree with his
libertarian positions of like leave me
alone i'm like i like that see the issue
is
if you're a true left libertarian you
are better off
voting for and supporting right
libertarians real ones the problem with
like the libertarian party is they're
all kind of like out of their mind
except for
now you've got you know dave smith and
these caucus guys who are pretty savvy
and on the level
but here's the thing there's no
situation by which you can vote in the
modern system left libertarians and
actually get a cooperative system that
you want
but if you have in a ron paul style
government of limited government then
you and your friends can be free to get
together and do what you want to do
without being oppressed by outside
forces which really should be you know
that's that's americanism that's like
what that is it's an individualistic
perspective what we have on the left
these days is so much but it's about um
you know these principles that they they
tout these principles of compassion and
whatever else but there's literally
nothing that they wouldn't sacrifice for
this mythological conception of the
greater good we were we were talking
about this with with uh vosh i think
this was on the bonus segment because i
i didn't talk as much on the bonus
segment we argued a little bit more and
uh
i think charlie had brought this up
charlie cook breaths up and then i agree
that basically
there's there's no real good way to
scale left libertarianism
because the idea of libertarian
socialism eventually becomes
authoritarian because there's no way to
enforce once the lines of communication
go six degrees of kevin bacon then
you're forcing people to do things they
don't want to do it's it's an impossible
thing to scale all governments probably
become authoritarian right well right
libertarianism to a certain extent
maybe not and i don't mean far right
like laissez-faire capitalism i mean
like leaning more towards free
enterprise with light regulation like
very light then you'll end up with
people choosing where they want to live
buying what they want to buy it's it's
negotiated it's trade but you got
corporate authoritarianism in that
direction that's why i said let
regulation so you have you have the
means by which the people can still
cooperate to stop the centralization of
power and so here's what i'm saying if
there is a left libertarian system
how does it expand to actually encompass
and guarantee your rights in a large
space where you're hundreds of miles
away from somebody else you need like
isolated pockets of it that can
co-interoperate
but so the issue then is
there's not so if you if you had a
government that was left libertarian
that is encompa encompassing the entire
state
you then have people in the northwest
part of the state saying i don't agree
with the southeast is imposing on us and
now you are getting into
authoritarianism it's not necessarily
that it is authoritarian it's that
people are not going to start fighting
and it's hard to have a cohesive system
if the system itself is right
libertarian then you can be like us here
up in the northwest we operate on the
left libertarian principle of
libertarian socialism if you want to
move here here are the rules if you're
not that's fine you can go and do your
own thing and then everyone agrees and
they all work together and they can
share their vegetables without using
money and then the right libertarian
people is the overarching system where
it says we're going to leave you all
alone
unless there's the non-aggression
principle and unless you've got the
currency and the negotiating skills you
can't come in and screw with these
people then on your own little hippie
farm you can do whatever you want
that i think works out pretty great
maybe unless except that it's a very
similar type of thing right because you
still then have a
sort of group ideology that rules
everything and individuals are not
permitted to go against that group
ideology but like in a small farm
i don't know like if i sort of like that
type of thing i mean if it's your farm
right then it's like your actual farm
then i wouldn't move there if i didn't
want to go along with your thing but
like then we're also you know cults do
that too like did you guys see that
netflix documentary about uh that little
town in oregon that was taken over by
this weird cult it was like no
wow weird like public sex cult thing it
was very it's very interesting it's
weird
i'm saying there there's there's one
very famous community but they pushed
out all of the people who lived there
originally so the people who lived there
originally had this sort of they were
just like doing whatever you know they
were mostly older folks
uh retired there was like a little cafe
or whatever so these cold people moved
in they all started wearing the exact
same outfits all the time and they
basically ran for city government and
they pushed out the people who were
there and they took over the town right
that's a that's when you get an
authoritarianism that's why i'm saying
left libertarianism doesn't scale
it eventually just becomes authoritarian
so the the the true ideal of left
libertarianism would be like a farm
with like a bunch of hippies hanging out
and they're friends with each other and
they're a family or whatever
i get a little utopian
it i there's a very famous one that's uh
got a hundred uh a hundred person
capacity and people apply and then they
say here are the rules and then they
come in and they stay as long as they
want and when they're done they leave
and then it opens up a position for
someone else somebody else can come in
yeah so it cap it's kept at 100. and
everyone knows the rules and everyone
agrees and they you know arbitrate
disputes between people but for the most
part it is
a cooperative and the people with
seniority are the ones who
basically say like okay if you're new
here we're going to protect the people
who are here but people rotate
interesting you get bigger than that and
it start you start
swallowing up other people's
jurisdictions and then it just becomes
why can't we why can't we have a city
that uh respects people's individual
liberties and doesn't capitulate to
authoritarianism
like maybe a nice nice big city with
some because people don't want to work
that's that's probably it so i think i'm
so happy to work i'm so grateful to have
a job all the time i'm like yeah i have
a job but look at what we're looking
look at what we're seeing now with the
the current
the current trends in in business the
labor shortage
i i saw somebody post uh somebody posted
a meme and they were like it was it was
two two stands like you know kiosks and
one had a huge line of people and the
other didn't and the huge line of people
said 17 an hour and the other kiosk said
minimum wage and then they they
commented like maybe if these businesses
paid better wages people would want to
work there and i say that's not true the
problem is that they're not paying
enough it's the government's paying them
for nothing well that's what the
president said the president basically
told there was like a one of those
stupid town hall things on cnn and a
business owner was like hey i can't get
anyone to come work at my restaurant and
biden was basically like maybe you
should pay more so you guys like oh yeah
i should i should pay more with like
restrictions and you know how is he
supposed to make any money if he can't
get anyone to work there so it's it's
obvious
if you're paying someone 16 bucks an
hour not to work that means they can
literally sit there staring at the wall
or play video games
if someone comes and says 17 an hour to
work 40 hours you'd be like you're
paying me a dollar an hour yeah i don't
want to do that because this because
zero has now become
16 bucks an hour right the interesting
thing about this is that people will
accept the 300 bonus check until 300 is
literally worth nothing because think
about it let's say right now the
government's like okay 300 per week is a
bonus and you're thinking okay 300 bucks
that can buy me enough groceries for
about a week inflation hits because
they're mass printing of money without
any resources being produced so within a
couple of weeks or a month now you're
you're like okay 300 bucks can get me
about 65 of the way through the week in
terms of groceries i'll take it's free
right
that carries on until eventually you're
like 300 bucks it's a free cheeseburger
right i'll take a free cheeseburger
right no matter what happens it's just
it's free something no matter how much
or how little is it is a free something
so until 300 becomes worth zero people
will never give up free money granted a
free cheeseburger you'll start to get a
job then but then we're still driving
hyperinflation how big the cheeseburger
is but yeah i mean i think also part of
the devaluing of work and devaluing the
worth at work ethic
is part of our culture that devalues
life
we devalue the individual we say you
know you're not worth anything unless
you're famous you're not worth anything
unless you're rich or any of these other
things you know
be driven by your pleasure principles
don't be driven by uh
interest and responsibility and you know
stewarding families or any of this you
know we're
the the message that we get is to like
it's idiocracy right it's my judge's
idiocracy it's like sit around jerk off
eat cheeseburgers and don't care about
yourself don't care about
other human beings don't care about your
own
worth if aliens ever come to earth they
will shake hands with humans not because
they overcame nuclear weapons but
because we overcame the xbox that's a i
can't remember that what that quote is
from it's a little bit old because
xboxes are a little bit old yeah well no
i mean everyone plays playstation right
that's the real issue no anyway the
point is
uh
video games are you shilling for
microsoft right now no i'm mocking them
for being you know less popular
video games trigger you know dopamine
right it's replaced our actual goals and
drives and desires we are addicted to
not doing
we're not doing substantive things i've
been feeling nihilistic lately and it's
partly i think and i'm kind of trying to
locate why what i've come to is i keep
wanting to solve the world's problems in
its in this lifetime i feel like i can
and i'm going if i don't then i've
failed and it's driving me insane
because it's such a big
problem and group think and herd
mentality and i realize or at least i'm
thinking maybe we're just planting the
seeds of the trees we'll never see with
yeah well of course it's a it's a long
game it's a long project but also
isn't the project have a lot to do with
doesn't the project have a lot to do
with um
how we interact with each other in a
personal level how we go about our daily
lives being kind to each other is so
meaningful
you know like
i don't think that that can be
overestimated i sound dumb and
pollyannaish you know and i've been
accused of pollyannaism before polyanism
where you're just like hopelessly
optimistic despite uh
it's this is meteor
it's a dog sitting in a burning building
but i do think that i do think that the
what really matters in life are the kind
moments that we have with one another i
think that's what
i think that's what i i wanna i wanna i
wanna i'm gonna we're gonna jump into
this guy right here phil defranco we're
gonna talk about philadelphia okay um i
should be a big fan of phil defranco he
was his own guy he started on youtube a
long time ago one of the ogs and he
built up this uh this news
company he had source fed and i was
always i was always like man this guy he
works hard he was calm rational
reasonable he interviewed gary johnson
he brought alternate alternative voices
to the political debate and i was like
this is cool it is cool to see that
through youtube we can we can hear more
from people like you know the
libertarian party granted the
libertarian party
little jack sparrowy but uh today i just
see these tweets from a minute it's like
he's just become so mean
he was always kind of snarky like that
yeah yeah yeah but it's one thing
i don't know man maybe maybe i'm just
wrong but
uh i've met him couple times i've talked
with him and he always seemed to be
willing to listen and kind of more
reasonable like when the media ecosystem
was was on tv yelling and and and things
like that he always presented the news
in a way that was more so like well
let's take a look at what they're saying
and why like let's be reasonable here's
what he has now
phil defranco tweeted
imagine having the cr the eligibility
and access to get the vaccine and saying
nah also to the pearl clutchers offended
by this tweet yes i am calling you
stupid and you can go f yourself you
ignorant selfish f-face
he then posted again
f man damn it this isn't me i missed the
mark i would really like to apologize if
you'll give me the time to read this i
saw that tweet when he said that and i
was like that's cool man that's like
phil and then i read what he actually
posted
just kidding hahaha f you again and the
people saying oh wow name kong is really
going to convince me i'm done trying to
convince you that's over i'm just going
to mock you for believing a bunch of
f-face grifters monetizing
misinformation and or ignorance
ignorance over scientists using the most
recent and relevant info
so look
i'm not going to cry about it's like
whatever i don't know you know he does
his thing that's fine but
i saw that and i'm like what happened to
us
he wasn't always like that
no no no he was sexy phil dude if you
know phil in the early days his video
channel was so sexy straight up
which is straight edge phil yeah pure
phil being sexy in his bedroom all black
and white chilling mystery guitar man
writes his killer theme song it's phil
he's a normal dude but but even even
six years ago like the last time i saw
him at vidcon or whatever and he was
like hey you know he's really nice
really calm really chill now he's on
twitter just
calling people f-face and insulting them
i was thinking this about sarah
silverman too it seems like i don't know
if it's in indicative of celebrities
only but it seems like people that are
kind of tertiary are on the outskirts
watching what's happening have like a
snapping mental break moment and then it
comes out in some dumb twitter post
remember what sarah silverman but look
just get over it people like she just
had it yeah this is phil just having it
yes but he's also he also on the wrong
side of the covington kids thing
it's not it's it's been a gradual thing
where oh phil yeah the dudes like look
man
i'm not i'm i'm not going to cry that
he's calling people these these things
i'm asking i'm just asking like why is
that happening probably because he
doesn't have anyone around telling him
he's an idiot
i mean his wife's pretty cool but you
look at what happens when these things
happen right now there will be some
drama they'll be like oh you know tim
poole said x or whatever all i'm saying
is why do you got to be so mean to
people all the time why is everyone
constantly trying to be mean i don't
want to be mean to phil i was i'm
i was i was a big fan until i started
seeing him tweet stuff like this and i'm
just like i don't like people being just
mean directly to other people he's he's
got kids i think he has two kids now so
he's maybe he's being like overly
protective of it and bought into the
hype and i also want to say this is not
an excuse to be like a total dick though
also but i also did say what happened to
us i'm not absolving myself from any of
the responsibility for the things i've
said some horrible stuff to people in
the last 20 years and i'm just wondering
like man can we just kind of look i'm
not going to be unfair to myself i
genuinely try to avoid directly
insulting and name calling i do a very
good job but sometimes i'll mock people
and i'll like you know i'll do like you
know really snide impersonations of them
but i genu i generally try to avoid
things like this that are just really
nasty really low really angry and mean
no forgiveness that's like the key thing
here like what happened to being like yo
let's work this out let's be nice to
each other but one thing that is going
on too and we can go back to the i mean
discussing this vaccine passport
situation is that is bullying right
saying to people you can't go to work
you can't work out you can't eat out you
can't participate in life unless you do
this thing that i'm demanding that you
do whatever it is whatever it is that's
a bullying thing to do that's a mean
bully thing to do and so i understand
from the same people who are constantly
saying like oh don't bully we have to
have special sessions in all of our
schools and so here's one here's not to
be bullies here's what i want to point
out when he says i'm going to mock you
for believing a bunch of f-face grifters
monetizing misinformation and or
ignorance over scientists using the most
recent irrelevant info
you know that you know the the the nail
in the coffin for me this one for me on
this one is one of the biggest issues
from upmc university of pittsburgh and
carnegie mellon university researchers
and researchers identified groups
hesitant about covet 19 vaccine and they
say
hesitancy held constant in the most
educated group those with a phd by may
phds were the most hesitant group while
vaccine hesitancy decreased across
virtually all racial groups they say
blacks pacific islanders had the largest
decrease they mentioned that those with
high school educations or less were the
most likely to reduce their vaccine
hesitancy so here's my my overall point
about
what what phil is doing
not only is he being really really mean
to people but he's oh he is also very
very wrong about what he's talking about
the people who are being misled or you
know whatever are not
mo like first of all why would you be
mean to somebody who is confused by by
lies
like if people when people believe bad
things i don't say you're a stupid [ __ ]
i say that's not true let me show you
the proof
so why come out insult them and it turns
out of all the people he's criticizing
he's criticizing people with phds now i
can't tell you why people with phds are
the most hesitant i have no idea so the
point is are we going to pretend like
people with phds are stupid okay well
isn't that the science in academia we
have a re we have a very serious
conundrum of perspectives here this is a
this is this is this is science
we're supposed to trust science right
okay well carnegie mellon university and
university of pittsburgh are saying phds
are the most hesitant group
they're also academics and i want to
know why they feel that way i'm not
going to scream at them insult them and
deride them and i'm also i'm i'm not
trying to be mad at phil either i'm just
hoping people kind of chill out and we
can have real conversations again you
know what we did with charlie kirk and
vosh i thought was incredible and
there's a photo of all of us we're all
just standing together and everything
and i'm like look at that man you know
they they come here they meet they laugh
they make points they don't agree with
each other at all but at least we can
have something where we can sit down and
be cordial twitter is a nightmare we
should we should just you know what i'm
for one regulation right now ban twitter
just go ahead get rid of text
communicating and text that's where all
this this dumb
miscommunication is seems to be stemming
but where's the anger coming from dude
from like the lack of emotional
interaction like when it's all taxed
when i etch something on a wall and then
you walk in and look at the wall we're
not having that emotional connection and
so i can see where the anger works i
build i write tweets all the time
i'll write a tweet and then i'll delete
it yeah i do that today i do it like
seven times a day i'm like here's how i
feel and i need to share that yeah you
got it too i kind of should have done
that the other day
why what did you tweet i tweeted about
how new york city's vaccine passports
are a total disaster and i'm definitely
going to leave new york
people are like oh let me have your
apartment and i'm like girl the joke's
on you yeah that was uh that was uh dana
schwartz it was a couple of people so
there was um but no it doesn't get good
light and it's not in a neighborhood you
want to live what neighborhood well so
you're not going to say
you posted a tweet saying the vaccine
passports were wrong
and then it actually made it to the
front page of reddit
all right the funniest thing about it
was the comments were all calling you an
anti-vaxxer right
and it's like you you're you're
vaccinations yeah i'm vaccinated
and but see that's the thing yeah this
is the tribalism the point is that the
point is that
that's my choice nobody should have to
show their medical status in order to
move freely about society it's insanity
and their id and their ideas show your
papers we always
we should have a right to live
anonymously in our cities for god's sake
well it's not only that it's that how
how many times have we heard showing
your papers was the wrong thing that we
should never have the authority
demanding papers from people going about
their business you have to watch saying
anything about that too i mean you have
marjorie taylor green comparing you know
vaccine passports and mandates and
things like that to
uh third reich
things and she gets totally slammed for
it so i mean you can't
there's also this there's also this
thing where you can't make comparisons
to historical realities
this is whether it's right whether it's
right or wrong this is the perfect
example of tribalism the fact that when
they see your post saying like we
shouldn't mandate this stuff the
response is anti-vaxxers are so dumb
even though you are vaccinated it shows
that they don't care about reality it's
the other
you know what i just watched the other
day have you guys seen electric dreams
no it's on amazon it's a philip k dick
yeah shorts or whatever do uh dude you
guys got to watch the 10th the final
episode i think it's episode 10 maybe
episode 8 i don't know it is about this
guy and it's like in the near it's like
in the near future i guess and there's
one candidate left in the race and so
you vote to affirm that the president
and then this so this is a female
candidate and she's being interviewed
and she abruptly says kill all others
and then changes the subject to
education real quickly and then the
interviewer is like i can't believe you
would say something like like that about
education and then this guy's like wait
what
she just said kill all others why isn't
anybody talking about this and he gets
his wife and she's like what are you
talking about i don't care he goes to
work and he's telling all his friends
and they're like man who cares about
politics right then a few days later
there's a billboard that says kill all
others and there's a person hanging from
a noose and then they're like it's just
politics man it's a it's a gimmick it's
a dummy and so this guy keeps coming out
and saying like why are you doing this
why are you advocating for this and the
people go what are you an other
why are you defending them he's an other
and that's how you identify yourself it
was a brilliant episode and the gist of
it is basically the authority makes a
declaration if you oppose them you are
the person they're talking you're the
problem and that's what's happening now
if the government says we're gonna do
something abusive and authoritarian and
you say i don't think you should do that
they say then you're the nazi you're the
fascist you're the anti-vaccine you're
the problem
yeah that's it's risky when you're
dealing with totalitarian regimes
because if you come out against them
you'll get murdered but if you
create an
alternate path
that often can work
it is it is extremely
creepy to me what's happening with
everything about how
you you quite literally have people who
last year were were vaccine or
antibacters and we all called them
anti-vaxxers hilarious right now like
those people who wouldn't get their kids
vaccinated for against like the measles
and so we had like a measles outbreak in
california
i'm talking about last year when they
were all of these blue checks were
ragging on fda in the cdc and the big
you mean like when kamala harris was
like i wouldn't trump trust a trump
vaccine and cuomo and then all these
other personalities can i tell you
something so we wrote about that uh the
kamala harris vaccine thing um we wrote
like a little we wrote about at the time
kamala harris as opposed to the trump
vaccine you know or whatever it was some
headline and then recently we wrote
about it again we were like let's just
remind people that she said she wouldn't
trust a vaccine you know from the we
were fact checked for that and it was
like
she's this is what she said the the
article was this is the thing she said
right do you guys remember this is the
thing she said that's all it was it was
like it was like a picture it was like a
blip it was like 200 words it was
nothing it was like a um i think it was
was it
science feedback maybe it might have
been science feedback but also the thing
do you remember in the spring
doctor senator
rand paul was talking to fauci and they
did like two segments there was like a
march segment and then a little later
and similar questions so we wrote a
story about like this is what he said in
march this is this was their
conversation in march this was their
conversation in may we got fact check
for that for for not enough context we
literally wrote down the things the
senator said
to the doctor we wrote those things down
did you see that facebook that was
missing context it was literally the
conversation facebook labeled the cdc
fake news no no
there was a cdc article saying that they
were recommending a change in the pcr
test to do like a better test and then
because of a fact checker
label like i guess what people were
saying was like ah this means the test
didn't work and then the
fact checker responded to that link
saying that's not true it did work it's
just a change in methodology but it
automatically applied the fake news tag
to all of the posts
that post from the cdc amazing
because social media knows better they
know what the narrative is and anything
that diverts from the narrative is false
well i hope you're ready for this one
we're in for a wild ride
nbc news says mandating vaccines amid a
worker shortage could spell trouble for
corporate america it's so hard to find
workers now that if you know a certain
percentage of your workers are going to
quit due to a vaccine mandate you're not
going to disrupt that said one hr expert
so we're in a labor shortage we've got
10.1 million job openings
and
we don't even have that many people
available for for work they've said now
the ratio of jobs to people is 0.9 down
from one it used to be like for every
one job we had people who weren't
looking for work
now we have more jobs i guess you could
say it's a good thing it means like
people are like hey we're open for
business we need employees but
it's actually a really bad thing yeah
that means
the the economy won't be able to recover
we don't have the people nobody will
work and now that they're doing mass
mandates and vaccine mandates at a lot
of these businesses people are going to
quit it's going to get worse
and also yeah i mean
i wouldn't want to go to work and
dehumanize be dehumanized and to
humanize the people around me i wouldn't
want to do that either especially you
know when i buy a 300 cheeseburger
that's right if uh if inflation gets to
those levels then you can have your 300
cheeseburgers yeah you know what i
really love i i made a point where i
said when we had john schneider on the
show papa john he mentioned in the
members segment that he knows a pizzeria
where they're paying 35 bucks an hour to
people for people to make pizzas which
is that's unheard of yeah and then i was
like okay so enjoy your 50 pizza and
then i get all these people being like
tim in sweden cheeseburgers are still
only five dollars and they have
sweden is like one of the largest
weapons exporters per capita don't come
to me and talk to me about what's
sustaining their economy okay i'm not
saying that quite literally overnight
your pizza's gonna cost fifty dollars
because they're paying 35 bucks an hour
right now
what i'm saying is
sure at a store with massive volume
where they're doing hundreds of
cheeseburgers per hour they can
accommodate higher salaries and wages
and they should absolutely sure
mcdonald's and burking all these places
they should pay more they have massive
profits same is true for walmart but
when it comes to a small mom-and-pop
pizzeria if you got to pay someone 35
bucks an hour how many pizzas are you
making per hour it's going that's that's
a 50 increase in labor costs yes your
pizza is going to go from 12 to 14
and then people are like it's only two
bucks who cares i'm willing to pay that
if it means that people are going to
have better salaries right and better
wages health insurance and health
insurance people deserve health
insurance
i think the bigger problem is that
health insurance shouldn't come from
employers right we need to find a
solution to that that makes no sense but
the the issue ultimately is that it
ripples throughout the entire economy
it's not about the one pizza costing 14
bucks for you right now it's that the
guy who can't feed his family because
it's too expensive now asks his boss for
a raise and it goes up across the board
yeah it does yeah well that's inflation
that's the problem with it yeah well so
this is the these mandates what people
don't realize is that people are going
to leave cities they're going to quit
their jobs it's going to make the
economies worse in all of our big cities
maybe yeah no it is going to make i mean
i'm not going to go anywhere that
requires me to show paperwork in order
to enter i specifically absolutely will
not i'm going to make it impossible for
me to do that i'm going to like destroy
my vaccine card so that i can't
you know i can't people have already
lost them you know
they ought to like let's all lose them
there was a video in italy they're
burning their their passes
well they should vas say this on the
show and i thought it was a really good
point because i hadn't considered it he
said the problem with vaccine mandates
for like new york for instance that a
lot of people already lost to their
cards yeah it was too big it didn't fit
in your wallet they know what to do with
it nobody cares like i got vaccinated
and that's done now
the other thing too is they kept saying
they weren't going to do it so people
are like oh okay i guess i don't need
this well the federal government
promised they said it over and over
again i mean you had gensake in the uh
briefing room being asked this question
over and over are there going to be
federal vaccine passports and no we're
not going to have a vaccine credential
that we're not going to do that
absolutely will not we will work with
businesses who intend to do that and
make sure that they do that and in the
appropriate way there will not be a
federal credential uh even if there's
not a federal credential there should be
a disallowance of any sort of credential
that mandates that that should just not
even be allowed what was that mean um i
think who mentioned it it was like a
whole lot of people who uh
what was it
oh man i'm forgetting it because i just
forgot it wasn't my tongue okay it was
like a whole bunch of people who were
like anti-fascists are now show me your
papers oh yeah something like that quick
switch from yeah yeah last year yeah it
was like opposed the dictator now it's
show me your papers
and that funny how that works the
interesting thing too with trump is when
you ask people what were some of his
authoritarian fascist policies they
can't actually name any it was just
resist the individual that you really
really think is over the top and
obnoxious did you see ben shapiro on uh
bill maher
yeah so one of the things that bill
maher said when he mentions benchmarks
and i talked to him last week i did an
interview with benjamin that was
interesting yeah he has the the
authoritarian moment his new book and
bill maher was like i thought you were
going to talk about trump and i'm like
please tell me trump what i can we can
talk about war and foreign policy
because that's what every president's
been doing and i'll agree with you there
for sure but trump did a whole lot of
nothing in a lot of ways yes that's
great he didn't shut down the riots he
wagged his finger and said oh the
radical left and then didn't do anything
that's a really good impression
so they call him an authoritarian and
i'm like for what why yeah there's no
there's nothing to back it up it's just
a word that this is used for someone you
don't like it's the other it's that
other thing i guess the idea the one
thing i could say
is the
people who are willing to believe like
just follow trump no matter what trump
said
but that wasn't the majority of
conservatives conservatives like the
republicans the people voted for trump
were more than willing to criticize him
as evidenced by the fact that you
actually have this weird agreement like
independent voters and republicans are
leaning in the same direction right now
clearly independents people who probably
vote libertarian and third party
aren't republicans
but they all recognize the economy is
not good but for some reason the
democrats you want to know what
authoritarian is authoritarian is when
the economy is in flames
nobody's working massive job openings
we've got uh
warnings from our mainstream media
saying this is going to get worse
because the mandates and the democrats
being like i think the economy is going
great
you know fairly good i get confused when
you say the democrats are you do you
mean the the politicians or the people
that are registered
i'm referring to uh poll which says
democratic voters believe the economy so
they're not democrats like they are only
the people the only the politicians are
considered democrats the voters are just
people they're not democrats or
republicans so the way the polling works
it asks you which party you're
affiliated with that's they are
democracy because when you say the
democratic party's full of idiots i
think of congress and that in a lot of
ways i agree with you but the people
that register as democrats i don't want
to put them in that in that ballpark
that's that's but they are they're the
ones who are doing this voting i've
registered a democrat for like two years
i was waiting oh you're right i was
welcomed i'm a registered doctor yeah
you're not a democrat though you're
registered to vote for that party is the
economy doing good no it's terrible why
is it then that independent voters and
republicans recognize that but
democratic voters think the economy is
doing good because they watch msnbc and
i think libby that's what it means when
they say rachel maddow they identify as
democrats they all believe the same
thing whatever the authority tells them
they follow that's authoritarianism
mindset that's authoritarianism strict
adherence to what the authority tells
you it's like michael brzezinski said
it's her job to tell you what to think
remember
it's the narrative i mean it's that's
what everybody is fighting over in media
too that's what everyone is fighting
over it's like uh
every you know there's like two stories
that are being told and the media is
arguing over which story is the accurate
story and people aren't wanting to just
put out facts and say this is the thing
that happened this is the thing that
this person said i i don't think the
media is doing that i think you don't
think so you don't think that the media
is like intentionally skewing towards a
specific narrative they are but you but
uh what you said was something more
specific what i'm saying is
they're not trying
what the media is doing
is they're saying whatever at the time
will benefit them politically that's all
they're doing they're opportunistic
they're not talking about making anyone
here to
yes
and the problem the authoritarian
authoritarianism comes from the people
who are like
oh rachel maddow said the other day that
she doesn't trust vaccines but today she
says she does so i guess i will too
that's authoritarianism rachel maddow
said so don lemon said so let's just do
whatever they say
[Music]
meanwhile you have regular people who
are like dude like i i voted republican
for the first time
you know uh donald trump i never i voted
for obama before him in 2020. yeah the
uh i don't want to vote for i wouldn't
vote for trump again probably you would
not vote for no i i think desantis is
the right is the better choice but to be
completely honest i'd rather have a dave
smith
although i recognize the libertarian
party's
weakness in terms of two-party system of
this country we'll see how things play
out i really really despise the idea of
voting against the democrats or voting
against the republicans yeah but i think
desantis has done fairly well i think
he's a pretty interesting guy yeah so
we'll see if he has actual ideas
unusual
if
if trump comes on here and talks about
fusion then i will fully support him but
really yeah if he keeps
doing 20th century technology he's got
nothing i got nothing i think trump has
shown us that
look he may have been the molotov
cocktail in the machine he may have been
the ball in the china shop we got to oil
that man yeah you like that ring ringing
but
but he made so many mistakes yeah he
should have fired a ton more people but
i think a lot of people saw trump as an
opportunity for something outside the
establishment that's disturbing because
that leads to authoritarianism because
no it doesn't yeah the authoritarian is
crackback is against that authoritarian
mindset of like i love this guy he's
going to just break it
i don't know about that i mean because
they're just blindly following him and
so now we're going to revolt against it
i don't think it was blind following of
trump right and i was opposed to trump
in 2016. um i definitely was not in
favor you know i went to the women's
march whatever stupid but
but i think that what you had at the
time when trump was elected were
you know half of the population did not
see their views or their values
reflected
in any aspect of american culture or
political life
not in arts academia entertainment
anywhere not in media so when trump came
along and was like hey 75 million people
who don't see your values or views
reflected anywhere in the country in
literally anything you're capable of
subscribing to i'm over here i can
listen to you
i can give voice to you right like
that's sort of what he was about he was
like a figure that was able to do that
so when he was taken away right those
people are back to having absolutely no
voice only now they're thoroughly
publicly vilified as opposed to just
being vilified which they were
previously and ian you were describing
more so anarchy than authoritarianism if
someone says i will not adhere to the
authority structure and i will put in
place someone who is chaotic and
destructive to that system that is
anti-authoritarian
a lot of people as michael moore
explained were looking at the human
molotov cocktail the biggest fu to the
machine they hated the authority they
hate the establishment so they didn't
support trump some people were were
zealots for trump no joke that whatever
trump said would say they'd be like yes
and they believe crazy things but that's
a small a smaller element most people
were just like we need something
as a wedge in the door something that's
going to get us off this broken path
now for me i didn't vote for trump in
2016. i was like i don't care about any
of these people and then in 2020 trump
put out his agenda with like school
choice on it the opposition to critical
race applied principles things like that
he said we're going to pull he was
actively working to get our troops out
of it out of afghanistan and i was like
that right there right get the troops
home end this stuff okay i'll vote for
that plus joe biden's insane right
that's that's a terrible idea moving
forward that was very much like a rock
and a hard place when we were looking at
2020. it's getting bad now and so i
think desantis is great he's like trump
in a lot of ways but he's not a bombast
you know what i mean so of course the
media will go after him and try to
vilify him but he's more tactful he's
half the age of trump he doesn't appear
to be a narcissist either which i
respect
i don't agree with a lot of his
positions and so i'm not saying i would
vote for the guy i'm just saying i
probably would not support trump
considering we've learned our lessons
and we have an opportunity for you know
someone else that being said i've never
been a big fan of the two-party system
like i said i didn't vote in 2012 or
2016. and 2020 was only because
it was just a crazy time to be
completely honest and now i'm like it
may get crazy or probably will we're in
the low year where there's no elections
so things are calm views and ratings are
a little low everyone's kind of chilling
out midterms next year it's going to be
what do you think do you think uh do you
think the gop have a chance to
definitely take the house i think they
will take it you think so there's a long
way to go a lot of people are running
it's really fascinating to like see all
of these
uh what's the new term america first
america first people running
i kind of i'm interested to see what uh
what they have to say for themselves
this is what i'm saying i think people
have learned a lot of lessons and that
means that come 2024 i don't think trump
will be as necessary as people think he
was last year or even right now
i think we're already seeing early signs
that you've got a desantis perhaps again
not a i'm not a i'm not a conservative i
don't completely agree i'd be more
inclined to vote libertarian and that's
only because of dave smith
otherwise
i don't even know who i'd vote for yeah
i need some some like technology talk
from dave otherwise i can't get on with
like the whole break it down concept
like i've been listening to him lately a
little bit but he's been like yeah we
need to undo this and undo that and like
okay give me what are we going to do
what's next and i think here's the
difference like a technology board or
something i'm down dave let's do this
and absolutely and that's
i think the what's inspiring about
dave is that he's a guy you can talk to
he's not out of reach and out of touch
and more interested in
you know the consultants what they're
going to say what size shoe or color tie
or anything like that that's one of the
problems we have two-party system is
it's just machine regimented and trump
kind of broke that in a lot of ways but
back to what you were saying about all
these midterm people running people are
learning the lessons a lot of america
first types of a lot of um populist
types right are now running and there's
a huge opportunity i think what we saw
in 2020 the over performance in the mid
i'm sorry in congress of the republicans
it's going to be
it's going to be even crazier because
look
this is what happened with trump in
2016.
they they they take everything trump's
voters came out for trump and the
republicans but in 2018 trump's voters
did not turn out this is this is true i
went through the data 2018. in 2018
trump's voters were
less okay and so that for like the
midterms yes right so be so what
happened was in 2016 when trump's voters
came out they voted down ticket
republican
but because those people did not come
out in 2018 to a certain degree was lost
republicans ended up losing a lot of
seats because that's when we got like
aoc and all those guys right that's
right and i think 31 seats flipped from
a republican democrat because without
trump's name on the ticket the trump
voters so many trump voters were
first-time voters or independent voters
now we're moving into 2022 i think a lot
of people have learned lessons
and joe biden was the the will take
whatever we can get to stop trump right
now they've lost that
they have lost to the name trump as well
so how many regular people are going to
come out in 2022 all dancing and
cheering saying and
back the party that's been
doing by that point will have been doing
such a poor job of handling this uh
whole covet situation and that's
interesting too when you watch the poll
numbers dropping the worse kova gets and
the less
control over it the white house can
maintain
the more abundance ratings are going to
tank people are going to want him gone
he staked his whole presidency on
solving several crises and that's why
you see you know you saw so much with
covet but that's why they're trying to
pivot so hard to climb it they really
want to get to climate so that they can
tackle the next crisis and be heroes
again when you look at the disdain
people had for trump and they did i know
a lot of people don't want to believe it
but trump did increase his his voter
base by a large number he had more votes
than any sitting president in history
but biden got more and i hear from
people who like they don't believe it
and i'm like dude but i told you
yeah i told this to steve bannon i know
people who are as dumb as a box of rocks
who have no business in politics and
couldn't tell you
even the name of the parties right who
are posting videos going and voting by
mail or who are posting the videos of
getting their bouts and voting with them
and i'm like listen
i believe when they say like why why do
people vote biden but not down ballot
i'm like because they're not political
people they saw the celebrity on tv the
entertainment was shut down for a year
nobody could go to the movies and they
were being the people were screaming in
their face trump is evil and they're
like ah and so they just write biden
send it in
and the republicans were able to take a
bunch of seats in in in congress
now imagine what's going to happen
without the threat of trump and even the
down ballot votes they did get it's like
i think republicans are going to do
fairly well they only need to win what
like 11 seats
there's a long time between now and then
so i'm not going to make any predictions
i don't know i just think based on
current uh trajectory that may be a a
fair assessment but don't you think that
there's also a chance that the uh the
democrats are going to completely
overhaul the voting system yes i mean if
you look in california gavin newsom has
his recall election coming up but
california just made it possible i'm
pretty sure that you can print your
ballots at your balance yeah i saw that
and then there's a lot of people can
come and collect it for you and come and
advise you on that uh and they've done
such an incredible job the democrats of
vilifying the um
different voting integrity laws that
have sprung up in what like something
like
22
states 28 states yeah a lot like a whole
bunch of states and if you actually you
know they say they're jim crow and
they're exclusionary and discriminatory
and all of this stuff and if you
actually look at those laws if you take
the time to read the laws
they don't say what the white house says
they say
it's not about that and if you read hr1
like i did a deep dive into hr1 it's 800
something pages
of rules about voting that have
absolutely nothing to do with anything
other than preventing states from making
their own laws so i looked up the um
it's called the remote access remote
accessible vote by mail is this the
california thing yes you can print your
selection sign the envelope and then
return the printed and signed selections
either by mail or dropping it off in a
voting location uh the selections cannot
be returned electronically so the answer
is yes
you can request to vote at home print
out your your
says you download the application mark
your selections print their selections
sign the envelope using the envelope
provided with the vote by mail ballot or
the voter's own envelope
cool that is not sketchy at all
this is from
sos.ca.gov
return the printed and signed selections
either by mail or by dropping off at a
voting location
uh
well there you go what you can now just
uh print out your vote this is you know
ian this is the opposite of blockchain
yeah
this is where my nihilism is coming from
it is blatantly obvious that if you have
a proprietary voting machine counting
votes it's not secure and that we have
an opportunity to attempt to secure it
with a third blockchain like you still
do what we're doing plus a blockchain
layer
but literally zero security on the
system so that's obvious prints out your
ballot how how has that not been adopted
that that to me either shows that people
are are very stupid in general and we're
just destined for extinction or there
are nefarious things stop keeping it
from happening which i think is more
likely which is terrifying but how do
you how do you how do you solve for that
humans crave to be told what to do they
don't want to think for themselves you
see we're divergent we are the weirdos
who for some reason want to be
responsible for ourselves everyone else
just wants to be gently patted on the
back as they rest in the lap of you know
daddy biden i mean is it because that's
so terrifying to like
do you say that
like is it because people that are truly
free are dangerous
to society people who are truly free i
don't think they should be perceived as
dangerous our country was founded on the
idea of the individual having you know
individual rights superseding group
rights and it's reversing course now now
we're being told that we are idiots and
cursed at you know by
various youtubers or whatever because we
believe that individual rights supersede
group rights but obviously that's the
only way to ensure that there's equality
is to put the individual's rights first
you know what is it the whole thing
about like uh you know it's better that
that
100 guilty men go free than one innocent
man be imprisoned that's still true
that's still true you know what i love
about that franklin took that quote from
someone i remember blackstone blackstone
said it's better that two guilty people
i think it was the original quote was
two to one are you sure i think it was
the original it's like a greek quote
blackstone's formulation is that greek
no it's it's it's uh it's it's from
blackstone it's rooted in the story of
sodom and gomorrah well well the cool
thing is that that makes a lot of if it
is ten i thought it was two but if it's
ten then he took a uh a power of ten he
took a magnitude great and then ben
franklin we should do that again it's
better than a thousand people go that's
why i agree with you that's why i oppose
uh cash bill i think cash bail is wrong
yeah rich people buying their way out of
jail so this is like indulgences this is
a big issue in new york because crime
went up because they ended cash bail and
this is a progressive issue aoc is very
much in favor of ending cash bill and i
completely agree with her the idea that
there's like some working-class dude who
gets arrested and accused of a crime and
then they say now you're going to sit in
jail for two months until your court
date you lose your job you lose your
apartment your family doesn't know where
you are or things of that nature it
happens to people because you didn't
have the thousand dollars to pay bail i
think is wrong what we need is a much
speedier court system i mean we have
such
there was a there was a young man who
actually died in prison because he
couldn't afford bail and it was over a
stolen backpack and he didn't do it and
i think he died in like rikers or
something like that you are innocent
until proven guilty the state should not
have the ability to to punish you in any
way unless it's a violent crime with
with with probable cause and they the
judge you know can actually what about
what about like recidivism do you have a
well in what capacity what do you mean
like if you're arrested multiple times
for violations for crimes uh is there
any point at which the state can hold
you like there was somebody recently i
think it was like killed people uh we
were going to cut the yeah cover a lot
of this stuff i'm not remembering the
story but like someone was arrested a
bunch of times on gun charges kept being
released kept being released kept being
released and then you know
see that's the problem
if somebody is arrested on a violent
crime
and they say
here's the person your honor here's our
probable cause as to why we believe you
know this person did this the judge will
then say like
due to the threat you are remanded to
custody right that makes sense if it's
someone who is like a non-violent
defender and this is what the
progressives did
i'll tell you what they did wrong though
when they say this guy was arrested for
shoplifting
and say what's your probable cause well
witnesses say he was shoplifting that's
not good enough but we're gonna hold him
no
cash bail is basically remand okay
that's not fair to someone who's working
class and can't afford it the problem is
you can't defend yourself
right you can't defend yourself you are
not secure in your person so what
happens is there was one guy who like he
got he was shoplifting like 30 times
right and they kept arresting him and
cutting him loose because the end of
cash bail and then he laughed when he's
getting arrested so i guess he said
something like i just keep doing it you
keep letting me go
it's like he was absolutely flouting the
rules he knew what he was doing right
see there's limits if someone does it
multiple times your honor this is the
third time this person's been arrested
we have numerous witness statements here
are the statements the judge can be like
okay
you're not getting out this time dude i
think we really need a much speedier
trial system how do you do it when you
got 13 million people in one city you
know a quarter in every corner 13
million what's what's the greater
metropolitan area
the people who come into the city the
greater metropolitan area of new york
though i mean you don't have like all of
those people aren't subject to the same
courts no it's difficult the people who
come into and out of new york so you you
can live in jersey and drive into new
york for work and then get arrested and
then you're in the system end up in the
tombs whatever else yep end up in the
tombs what an awful name it is awful i
remember when a friend of mine was like
he was like i just spent the whole
weekend in the tombs that's
this is what happens police officers
know that rescue friday you can't get
out till monday exactly
and that could mean you lose your job
yep so he didn't have one so it was okay
there i i i have had friends who have
been arrested uh wrongly on fridays and
then wait until monday to get out it's
insane it's crazy it's nice and they
lose their jobs it's like you're two
seven two
and during covid like a lot of the
courts were really backed up a lot of
things just didn't happen maybe we need
online courts
i don't know about that there's that
tendency that people won't won't fight
their own sit at their own neighbors so
maybe the problem with an online course
though is it removes the
it's like you were talking about earlier
with twitter right it's like it removes
the emotional aspect so when you when
you're a judge and you see a defendant
in a you know orange jumpsuit on a
closed-circuit prison camera
are you really going to
look at that guy and see his humanity
right no eye contact yeah there's
nothing there's nothing at all
do you think i'd be more guilty i think
there'd be more guilty yeah i mean i
think that we should have a speedy court
system
um where
an accused is brought before a judge
brought before a jury it shouldn't take
like months and months and months some
of these hearings take so long like just
to get to the hearing too many people
yeah one of the things that's uh it is
relatively easier for certain crimes
where it's like the cops themselves
witness it and they say we you know we
are witnesses but then they're still
agents of the state so it's very
difficult i don't like the idea that
credibility is given to the agents of
the state you know two people walk into
a court the cop says this guy you know
uh stole a banana and then the guy says
no i didn't the cop said yes he did the
court just believes the cop right you
know oh he arrested him and the cops
probably telling the truth and jerry
just believes the cop this is why there
are of course instances where the police
then plant the banana on the guy
well but yes but i think the most
important thing is that cops can make
mistakes and so i know a lot of people
on the left will be like cops plant
drugs oh we've seen it that body camera
footage where the guy puts the drugs in
the it's under a rock or something and
then i don't know what that is he
accidentally turned his camera on when
he thought he was turning it off
yeah but but more importantly
there's this really famous video on
youtube where a lawyer talks about why
you never talk to cops and he explains
that like the cop could miss hear you
and then tell the jury he confessed and
the jury's gonna be like okay
yeah that's a rule that i grew up with
which is
don't ever talk to cops about anything
ever anything ever if you're ever
arrested
shut up anything ever because you never
shut up you never know if you're the
suspect and people are like oh but if
you're just a witness you know that's
what happened to you you don't know that
that's the thing to like uh
you know in terms of calling police
officers for some reason if there's
something going on you have to be really
careful with that because cops show up
and they don't know who is who right and
so immediately they assume you know they
can make these assumptions that's a
difficult job
yeah and we're losing cops constantly
well you know how i feel about that
i'm not gonna uh stand for the cops who
are enforcing the lockdowns and mandates
and arresting salon owners and uh and
letting antifa go so
there was a woman in minnesota she
opened her uh cafe
in defiance of the lockdowns and said
you know screw off and the sheriff's
went and they tracked her down and they
arrested was this the bar owner and she
like had a couple of kids and she was
trying to i don't i don't know about the
details well there was there might have
been another one yeah i don't uh i don't
have any respect for officers who are
who are imposing and enforcing lockdowns
either look what's going on in australia
what happened to australia oh man got
colonized by the there was there was
apparently some story about a lady who
couldn't even cross over from like one
state to the next right like they've
actually locked their stakes or
something they've locked down everything
it that just seems insane to me they've
been telling me that it's different
areas too it's very different from area
right yeah but how do you stand for that
like how do you look at a police force
and say like yes i you know i will stay
in my one man who was 86 years old died
so 900 000 people have to get locked in
their homes it was one it was literally
one guy very old very old guy who you
know
probably died with covid in berkeley i
think this was in secaucus i could be
wrong a woman was she had a shop
and they locked everything down the
government ordered all businesses to be
closed
so she went on facebook live and started
filming what she had in her store saying
if anybody wants to buy anything just
comment below so the cops showed up
knocked on the door and they said ma'am
you need to close your shop and she said
what are you talking about we are closed
and they're like no ma'am you are trying
to sell things online you have to shut
your shop down why can't you sell things
online what about ebay only were they
allowed to sell things whatever was
going on and amazon was not about covid
because the cops came and told her to
stop live streaming on facebook yep
that's insanity where was that iconic
new jersey i think that's where it was i
have to look it up it was it was
somewhere it sounds like a new jersey
thing to have happen yeah it really does
and i'm sure it's not the only place we
saw that we saw that they were letting
people out of jail
and then they were putting that like
that salon owner in texas in jail yeah
and she was very forthright she was like
i have people who work for me and i
don't want them to lose their homes i
told my mom i was thinking about uh
leaving new york i was like i don't
think i can make this work anymore mom
and she's like just moved to jersey i
was like nope mom that's the same
actually worse it's place the same place
it's like stinky new york it's like true
yeah
i don't know man um what i i don't know
about what people in cities should do i
can't predict the future i do think
it'll just start getting worse i think
really
do you think i mean that's the
interesting thing it's like where can
you go i was talking to ben shapiro
about this because i was like you know
what happens when
people you know he was calling it like
the big sort you know like there's going
to be a big sort out what happens like
will it eventually overtake the entire
country is there any organization that's
going to be all right to live probably
like another internet just like live
like a free person and that's the other
thing too it's like is there going to be
an amazon for people who don't want to
support jeff bezos's crazy empire i hope
so did you see the polling showing that
um i think it's 37.2 percent of
americans want their region to separate
from the us to form its own regional
union really which which regions want
out does new england so they they yes
so well but they're all about a third so
they'll be crazy there they broke up the
the country into five regions you've got
the pacific region you've got i think
the heartland region the mountain region
the southern and the northeast and
most are the plurality
uh in terms of
i should phrase this better on the west
coast pacific region democrats were the
largest group that wanted to secede from
the union in the south that was
republicans in the midwest it's
independent voters okay but the overall
average among all regions when i
actually went through the math i went
through the population of each state
normalized for population 37.2 percent
of people in this country are in favor
of their area breaking off from the u.s
with the great sort you are going to see
those numbers dramatically increase
because the people in the pacific region
the 30 of republicans who are there and
want to break off will move to texas and
bolster the republican number there and
increase it i think 60 of southern
republicans wanted to break away i think
that's like i want though like i want to
eat cake every day like they don't
really want they don't know what it is
they're saying they want if you want to
militarize you want you want like a war
like five tribal
north american
you know 21st century don't that's how
you split it up then we'll all go to
fight each other that'd be crazy that
would be pretty crazy
nuclear weapons
well but we wouldn't all have numerous
finally we can use our tanks wouldn't it
basically be like hawaii would have we
wouldn't all have nuclear minnesota i
think minnesota would have nuclear
weapons and port cities right devastated
how many people understand the policies
they're voting for most of them seem not
to and so when people say i don't know
the politicians read the bills sometimes
you're right they don't what was it what
was the omnibus was wheeled in on a
wagon with 5000 pages and nobody read it
the senate just voted for that but yeah
it's ridiculous then it just does so the
senate was asked recently wasn't it to
vote for the massive giant stupid
infrastructure bill before it was
written because the house like refused
to take it up unless the senate promised
that they would pass something that the
house drafted oh come on there was a
collusion
that's what happened insanity and like
basically nobody read it because it
doesn't exist there there will be voting
certain amount of signatures to get
something as a referendum it'll appear
on the ballot in november and then
people will see it and as we already
know x amount of people in these regions
want to secede so when they're voting
it'll be like would you like your region
to become its own region they go oh yeah
for sure and they vote for it they don't
care about the other thing too is the
way that the laws are named they're
named in very obfuscatory ways so that
you don't really know what you're voting
for right yeah right like a like
like the yeah the patriot act
is the opposite of the patriot act or
like hr one they call you know they call
it like a for the people act
it's not at all it's actually like so
overreaching and authoritarian 16 year
olds voting yes that's what it hasn't it
it has like a provision that you have to
register people who are under 18 to vote
amazing that's in it let's go to super
chats if you haven't already smash that
like button go to timcast.com become a
member and you will get a bonus segment
coming up later tonight but for now
smash that like button and we will read
these super chats
all right let's see the crazy one says
should elon take the olympic flame to
space
i don't know why
nobody cares
all right cry1042 says the governor of
washington state mandated all state
employees and health care workers get
vaccinated by october 18th or lose their
jobs i now have a decision to make get
vaccinated or lose my job well i've been
telling people you know this i'm i'm in
favor of companies private companies
to a certain degree
mandating their employees get vaccinated
so i think first scale matters if it's a
company with like a hundred thousand
employees probably not so much there's a
lot of wide-ranging implications about
international law interstate law health
health rights but small businesses
definitely they're not even allowed to
ask are they yeah they are what's your
medical history when you when you apply
you're allowed to do that yes and and uh
companies are allowed to mandate
vaccines but they assume responsibility
for any adverse uh events they require
if they require some medical
intervention but here's the point
first of all when it comes to small
business i don't think the employer or
the employee they owe each other
anything we have an agreement right i'm
looking for someone to do work do you
want to do work here's my stipulations
no have a nice day i don't owe you any
money
so when small businesses are like here
are my restrictions i'm like okay well
you know like i'm not gonna tell a small
business they have to hire somebody
within certain reasons this is a big
moral challenge because i understand
there are certain things from like you
shouldn't discriminate on the basis of
race or identity and then you know when
it comes to vaccines it's like well like
now you're telling people they can't
discriminate for a certain reason but
ultimately you know it ends up happening
the people are now making the hard
choice of putting their money where
their mouth is no longer will you be
able to sit back and just let everyone
else fight your battles for you
unfortunately and we've all gotten those
emails it's like hey i really support
you but i'm never gonna speak publicly i
know i get them i can't i probably
aren't gonna talk to you and the problem
is when i was saying a long time ago if
these people are doing these things you
need to speak up now or forever hold
your peace when it was just critical
race applied principles people were like
i don't got to say anything well now now
they're telling you go to go get uh
something to get to get an injection
whether your doctor tells you or not
they have requirements now that's
between you and your doctor you go talk
to your doctor about what's right for
you but now you have a hard line will
you comply with medication or not it was
easier when it was crt
now
who will cross the line i gotta be
honest i think most people will you
think most people will cross the line
definitely i think there'll be a exodus
i think it will hurt the economy but i
think most people are going to fall back
on i will not stand up
right yeah i think i think you'll see
more people be pushed out and i think a
lot of people don't want to stand up i
think a lot of people just want to be
left alone
and they're but they're but they're also
not willing to fight for that so what
happens now when they're when they're
given this
i mean look like i said with crt people
are like i know it's bad but i can
ignore this because it's a long-term
problem your kids will inherit a trash
future okay i guess it's really i think
it's hard to ignore the critical race
theory stuff you know when your kid
comes home saying like mom are we racist
because we're white people
that's rough there are certainly there
are certain problems you see with
industry like pollution where you're
like we know it's bad but whatever and
then people keep buying their you know
products and stuff then there's the more
immediate where it's like crt and
critical race applied principles in work
and school and then you're like okay
this is getting harder to ignore but
what's the worst case and i keep my head
done i'll be okay now they're like sir
we would like you to get a medical
procedure i know a small one but still
now people are gonna have to make that
choice is this the line for them i think
for a lot of people it will be i think
for most people it won't be
there's got to be a line somewhere
though i mean we've we've given that so
much we've given up we give up
constantly this is the this is the
biggest thing that i've heard from
people who are you know like filling my
twitter with hate is like
but you you you've given up this already
you have these other restrictions that
we've gone along with why is this so
different you know
um that's a nice way of saying it but
well it's one step at a time people
accept it and we clearly shouldn't be
constantly capitulating rights after
rights it's just not acceptable we
clearly should have been standing up for
this against this kind of thing a long
time ago and we haven't it's the
exploitation of goodwill we thought 15
days to slow the spread was reasonable
and then it became 500 uh what are we on
500 and
no no it's like 512 or something 515
maybe it's a lot of days and it's
working i mean that's the thing too it's
like this they constantly as they
enforce these things and and throw these
things at us
there's this
underlying understanding that it's
actually helping that it's actually
reducing the virus that it's actually
doing
none of that is actually true we're
going to be living with this virus for
the rest of our lives for the rest of
human history probably or whatever it's
got animal repositories it's not going
away
so we have to figure out how to exist
in this reality we can't just imagine
that we're going to
completely eradicate it if we just all
stay in our houses and stop breathing
yeah all right let's read some more ian
kinney says hey tim did you see the hit
piece segment jank jugger did on you
lauren chen made a video about it no i
don't watch any of those things it's a
waste of time
uh it that's one thing you know
there's a video made about me every
other day why should i care if the young
trucks have opinions they're not
relevant
i i look at what's going on with the
world
and i just think
drama
oh tim poole did this that i don't care
who cares about me
i guess they do whatever
i don't care about me i care about other
stuff you know what i mean it's the
weirdest thing yeah that's how i feel
about politics sometimes it's like dude
this human drama that we created that
we're like spinning in this reality like
but i but i care about politics i kind
of like when aoc comes out and lies
about what happened in the capitol um
her whole story is fabricated by the way
because the the the time at which the
cop came to her door and knocked was a
few minutes before the first trump
supporters actually breached the
barricades really yes and i don't forget
that part
every conservative has every every
critic of aoc has missed this and no
matter how many times i said i dm'd ben
shapiro i was like we were talking and
then he was like oh that's actually a
good point so the cop knocked on her
door before they breached the capitol
yes to check on the hour before they
breached the capitol come on
no one knew so aoc comes out and makes
this whole thing up
so
what was he doing at her door what was
he doing at her door there was a bomb
scare
so totally separately oh that whole
other the bomb maybe she hid in the
bathroom because someone knocked on her
door that may be true but for her to
conflate that with i thought they made
it to my my office when it was an hour
before anyone but the okay there was
just no timeline to support that there
is the new york times did the whole
timeline note to support all right the
new york times the whole timeline of it
and reuters did a timeline of what she
claimed and for some reason no one put
these pieces together i feel like i'm
the only one who's done multiple
segments about it like
i don't understand why all the
conservatives keep coming out and saying
she wasn't even in the building she
never said she was in the building she
never said she was in the capitol
so i'm like
how come when i first reported on this
the huffington post uh tried
a reporter hit me up saying you're wrong
your timeline's wrong and then i was
like oh man so i deleted the tweet i was
like i i must have screwed up
then i went to the timeline again and i
was like another lick so then i messaged
him back and i said here's the evidence
and he went oh i guess i made a mistake
i'm like that's right
aoc said it was around 1 pm when the cop
knocked on her door that was because
there was a bomb reported and he was
coming they were they were given notice
they all had to leave aoc chose not to
for some reason so the cop had to go get
her
for her to then claim she thought the
protesters got to her her room the
conservatives all respond but her room
her office wasn't even in the capitol
building and then the fact check the
fact check is reuters says false aoc
never claimed she was she was concerned
that they made it through the tunnels
and then i looked at the timeline i'm
like it was an hour and 11 minutes after
the cop showed up at her door that the
first doors got breached at the capitol
building an hour and 11 minutes no one
thought these people were getting in the
building if they did there would be more
police at the capitol and if you think
that's not true then you got a problem
with the capital police because they
should if you think the capital police
knew that was going to happen and aoc
had knew it was going to happen why
didn't they call for more police she
lied anyway
what did you think of that hearing that
first day of the hearing nancy pelosi's
that's ridiculous it was such trash it
was such theater it was insane anyway
well to wrap up that super chat
i think it's i think it's funny when
people are obsessed with
non-political actors to such an extreme
degree
like i've criticized jan kuerker of the
young turks he's got a prominent show
it's feel free to criticize me i've got
a prominent show i'm mostly more
interested in criticizing politicians
and you know people with more power look
the people who are actually you know
changing things but to be fair
um the concern from the left is that the
show is very influential so by all means
criticize it the problem i have is that
they don't have real criticism
they're they're they're they're there's
a very serious challenge among the left
to try and figure out what's wrong with
what it is that i do
so i don't want to waste time you know
dealing with watching their stupid
garbage where they make stuff up
what are they going to say well tim
poole talks about universal health care
and agreeing with it but then he makes
fun of democrats it's like so does a
bunch of leftists fear they think you're
fear-baiting that's the main concern
because if you are projecting in the
future and like i think it's going to
get worse
it's not that you're saying it's going
to get worse but you're just projecting
one possible future that happens to be
terrifying vosh that i was far right
they're pissed at you because you're not
holding any specific narrative
i'm telling you that's what it is like
yeah you're not upholding one narrative
or another you're just actually you know
doing what you think is right and nobody
really quite understands a person that
does that anymore they really want to
call me far right
but i'm literally not i'm like i agree
with aoc on ending cash bail cash bill's
bad like well yeah well you're lying
it's like
i don't know dude make all the
headpieces in the world you want we got
we got a lot of fun stuff happening here
it was funny when vosh came and we were
talking with him before he came up we
were like we're doing a bunch of new
shows dungeons and dragons
paranormals and mysteries and i think
it's funny that like
the company so far has like a political
show and then like we're launching
totally not political stuff and they're
acting like it's the apocalypse probably
because they realize
because that's what's needed we need
culture we need more culture than just
the
leftist driven propaganda that we're
seeing come out of hollywood and yep yep
dude the songs oh i want to talk about
it the songs that we were working on the
other night dude they're so good
vocal harmonies yeah that's where it's
at well i got a bunch of songs ian was
was singing we got so they're so good
they're just it's just raw recording so
i'm not i'm not going to play it live
all right well some of that from the
musical i wrote about condoleezza rice
one time we got to read some more super
chats rant over david james says ian's
shirt is the best that's what i'm saying
it's true all right yes
all right let's see computer
solve this
southern survival says i'm 15 year
veteran currently on my fourth tour and
i'm worried about my career being
affected by my
by my refusal of the vaccine the dod is
going to mandate it soon i just want the
liberty i swore to defend well as i
always say um
talk get a good doctor you know if you
if you don't trust your doctor you need
to get a good one but
my understanding about people in the
army is don't you get a ton of vaccines
the moment you join
isn't that true no i have no idea the
stories i heard from people is that like
when you enlist you go to basic training
they give you a bunch of like vaccines i
mean prepare to be toxified if you're
going to the military they'll put you
right next to burn pets
they put you in a room with tear gas
yeah
they have like they have burn pits and i
think it's afghanistan where they just
all the trash is thrown in as just a 24
7 burn pit and then when the wind
catches it brings it over the base
everyone has to breathe that
all right super neal comic says i am
from canada and so much want to live in
one of the red states like texas and
become a u.s citizen nice i love you
guys see everybody wants to come to
america everyone wants to move to texas
yeah
all right
well what does that say waffle
what what i can't write wolf dolphin god
okay uh as someone who lives in
louisville the way she pronounced it
makes me want to smash my face into a
table i love the workout
lewisville i was like where's that
i've never been to kentucky
wow look at this
sei power says even north dakota is
being overrun by california and colorado
jeez
yeah
almighty media says tim you should have
politicians on ted cruz uh yes we would
have ted cruz on ted cruz come on the
show that'd be amazing um
like
you know look here's here's something
some insight like when we first started
the show we would send emails to people
and they would just click delete they
don't care they don't want to come on
the show and then a few months goes go
by and then people would be like oh you
know maybe sometime and as the show's
gotten bigger and more subscribers all
of a sudden now we're getting people
emailing us being like can we come on
your show so we're i'm not in the
mindset of like reaching out to ted cruz
and asking him to come on the show
but if ted cruz wants to come on the
show he'd be like yeah absolutely that'd
be fantastic
granted i will say politicians are the
worst bookings ever why they always go
i can i have i have politicians
following me and i'll dm them be like
would you would you want to come on the
show absolutely email this person they
can handle it and then you do and then
they don't respond then it just dies
that's right so it's a waste of time
yeah i talked to ted cruz last week and
it took like a whole bunch of like
running around like a crazy person to
get like what three minutes or something
yeah i don't think we're gonna get two
and a half hours out of these you know
politicians
all right aaron salman says so are you
talking about spiffies i live about 20
minutes from there it was an icon of the
i-5 corridor they had a dine-in to
protest restrictions people from idaho
and cali showed up there wasn't even
standing room to eat sad to see them go
bomber man
wow
capitalism entertainment and
technologies says calling it now tim
just heard country roads and moved also
most of texas texas left tends to be
libertarian druggie types at the moment
i'm totally cool with those that's
that's legit that's like ian basically
yeah that's my homies
[Laughter]
all in moderation
even moderation yeah only a good point
dallacourt says tim with all the blue
ties rolling into texas do you think
it'll dilute the liberal influence in
the coastal states allowing for some red
wins no
because red
voters and non-democrat voters are
leaving as well so you've got
conservatives fleeing new york
and you've got
conservatives fleeing california
and still the problem is the
authoritarian lockdowns hurt everybody
democrats and republicans so everybody
wants to leave the problem is the
democrats bring those same policies with
them not caring or realizing so
i do think it could theoretically dilute
some of their power and expand
congressional seats for conservatives
because
many of these democrat voters who leave
big cities to the suburbs of the least
are spreading out their vote into red
dominated areas it could flip some red
areas blue that are really close
but i think if you've got an area that's
like 55 percent republican 45 percent uh
you know democrat and then some
democrats move out to that suburb it
won't be enough to change
so you you don't think that any of these
democrats are going to change their
minds definitely not you don't think so
i changed my mind a lot of people
changed their minds i did i mean i've
never really party politics and it's and
it is true that a lot of democrats
bought guns
so perhaps i looked into trying to buy a
gun in new york city oh good luck
there were like interviews required you
know they wanted blood samples yeah all
right i was wrong about that people will
change their minds we got this tweet
christopher brown says i was far left
when i found you in 2018 and you have
helped me find my way back to the center
a few weeks ago you had on the guys from
fresh endfit and they helped me a lot
with my depression if i'd ever if i
never found if i never found you i'd be
dead right now tim you saved my life hey
man uh i really appreciate that and the
super chat and
you know what's what's crazy is
i think when going back to those smear
pieces they're like
there was one apparently i'm the most
dangerous political commentator i guess
because the reason is i'm a moderate and
that's really really bad for the far
left it's because it profits it creates
a real alternative if you're uh if you
grow up and you're left liberal and this
is the tribe it's the only space you
have where you feel safe and then
someone says well you can always be a
suit-wearing christian conservative they
go i don't i don't that's not me i won't
fit in i don't believe those things and
then you see
rock music skateboarding moderates and
that's like that makes more sense for me
it's creating apostates for the left it
does make more sense for a lot of people
i mean it's like you look at a lot of
the podcasts that are prominent
conservative and they're wearing suits
and they're very stodgy and you know
very business-like and you know ian's
basically wearing his pajamas every day
i bought more pajama pants i have seven
at least seven pairs which we where
we're and look at the shows we're making
dnd and skateboarding and skating and
and the you know the vlog and the
mystery stuff dude the tie is an upside
down noose why do people wear those
it's crazy someone just grab it
all right i wonder what the origin of
that is the heck it's like subservience
or something weird kicks it's probably
like quick quicks quick quick access
service guarantees citizenship perhaps
the way to accomplish this would be to
limit the ability for people to vote
they must show gainful employment unable
to work there should be other service
options available support the system to
earn a vote i really do like the idea of
service guaranteeing citizenship it
doesn't mean military and it doesn't
mean
labor it just means
contributes to the community in some
discernible way and you vote what if
that's like by getting the vaccine
contribute to the community by getting
your inoculation we would have to set
parameters
it would be like community service
so community service at your own
discretion is literally like going to a
community center and you need any help
and then they sign it for you and so my
high school had that
uh the high school that i went to and
never finished because i only went there
for like two months they make you do
community service before you graduate at
least i'm pretty sure that was the case
i didn't know cause i never did it
because i left and you know didn't
graduate so i had to do community
service for my confirmation hours but
also for my high school
oh see there you go yeah what did you do
uh for my confirmation hours i worked in
a like soup kitchen for like religious
confirmation yeah
okay conflict this is this is really
important
tiny uh what does it say tiny
timmy y'all is that i'm pronouncing tim
given your stance on 2a would you disarm
me a card-carrying ccl holder if i were
to visit the cast castle for one of your
public events oh no good question yeah
the answer is no no way the answer is
we're going to have security and we're
gonna vet the people who come and the
events aren't gonna be that big anyway
and uh
my attitude is
right to keep and bear arms if somebody
wanted to come here and hurt me there's
there's crazy ways you can hurt me or
anybody else so i'm actually
not worried and if someone lets me know
that they're armed that's fantastic
thank you for letting me know that's
great
uh i look forward to you defending us in
the event that someone does something
crazy people drive cars all the time
they're not running people over people
come here all the time for deliveries
and for whatever they're not running
anybody over they have cars they have
the means to cause harm they don't do it
i don't view a gun any differently i
don't see like other guy's got a gun
he's going to attack somebody i'm like
well i don't know whatever i got a gun
too so don't draw it
you know unless there's a life dain you
know i don't think there will be any
reason to
oh this is important martin edgar says
23 suite 50 room a 26 000 square foot
lodge in northern michigan for sale for
a mere 19.5 million
on 415 acres with 13 other buildings on
the property sits on lake superior new
vertical launch site being uh to be
built near beginning to be built nearby
search for granoloma
all right so let's just get 20 million
people to put in a dollar
a dollar each or or or
each and whatever one of our subscribers
to put in 20 bucks oh yeah and then
we'll uh we'll procure this here large
massive property and we'll start a city
let's do it not really but that would be
fun wouldn't it be so fun
i was looking at martha's vineyard
properties
that's super expensive my goodness
they're they're they're they're actually
at the most expensive i've seen
what's the most expensive i mean like
you look at parts of california in
silicon valley and it's like 20 million
40 million martha's vineyard had stuff
that was like 12 million but there's a
lot of places that are like a million
i like nantucket better honestly yeah
yeah but then you're like where do you
get your food from you're like on an
island you know yeah but so is martha's
vineyard no i know but like yeah either
one of them i mean i'm not moving either
of those places but still that's the
craziest thing about it i can understand
getting a mountain fortress in new
zealand but i can't understand getting a
multi-million well no i took that back
if you're worth a billion dollars you're
gonna be like oh whatever it's like it's
not a big deal to buy a multi-million
dollar property new zealand though new
zealand is bad because jacinda ardern is
insane yeah yeah but if you're uh one of
these billionaires there was a flight
as we saw this weekend right because the
rules don't apply to obama or al-kabadu
they definitely don't
all right let's see
uncle sam says earlier segment you said
people were crazy who questioned history
being right i don't know i'm not sure i
understand
i propose looking at dictionaries and
the changing definitions yearly then
think of first edition books anything
after a change correct what are those
changes
i talked about something with the third
you know biden is being accused of
filing the third amendment no what was
this so with the eviction moratorium
there's a group of lawyers who are
saying certainly many of the people who
are renting properties are soldiers
and if the government is mandating you
can't evict a soldier that is a
violation of the third amendment oh
that's interesting yes
and so
their argument is the whole thing should
be thrown out because there's no
there was no consideration given to the
idea of how they were strict soldiers
therefore the whole thing is bad but the
very least the court should say if if
you're an active duty soldier or if
you're a soldier of the us you know
armed forces anyway you can be evicted
which kind of sucks because of all the
people who would be evicted right i
don't want them to be evicted but still
however
the interesting thing is
the agents of the king who were
enforcing a lot of his edicts were the
soldiers right so when the count when
when the founding fathers were like
soldiers shouldn't be able to go in your
house but that's the quartering act that
one no third amendment
yeah right there was two quartering acts
one was in 1774 i believe and that was
like what really set everybody up right
yeah
the real issue i think was not that
soldiers were occupying homes but that
agents of the state were stealing
property from the people right
so what the third amendment should
actually say is
agents of the of of the government shall
not be able to claim seize or take
property from an american citizen
without due process
civil asset for forfeiture out the
window third amendment but the third
amendment says no soldiers you know
during peace time
shall you know be quartered in someone's
home or in or during war without an act
of uh of congress or whatever
with about an act of legislation or
something so
the perspective was in 1774 i think it
was the soldiers would go in your house
take your food sleep on your bed right
and they were like get out of here this
is yeah they don't like that
right now we have cops we'll actually go
in your house and use it for steakhouse
and things like that they'll seize
property from your vehicle i think all
of that should fall under the third
amendment
i think the issue is the language
changes the understanding of what the
issue was changes but the core element
of what the third amendment i think
represents is
being secure in your property from the
government just taking whatever they
want people never talk about the third
amendment the fourth amendment says you
know search and seizure right so i guess
that's why they're like oh well that
covers it but then what agents of the
state can just go in your house yeah
that shouldn't for different reasons for
whatever reason they want i mean again
the fourth time it does cover a lot of
this but the third amendment is a broad
protection of your property i think
should be considered and argued
all right let's see admar says my wife
and i are required for jabs at our jobs
have a three month old and standing up
for his future liberty not mine would
rather risk a job than risk freedom for
what it's worth both have doctorates wow
wow
so that's the that's the phd that's
right that's the phds
all right let's see mr obvious says
youtube took down my video which was 100
sourced by the cdc youtube is also
calling the cdc fake news the censorship
is out of control and that happened to
uh stephen crowder
the one thing you should have to say
always is
talk to your doctor
right there's the the the main reason i
say that isn't just because uh i'm
worried about youtube censorship youtube
does say like that's one of the things
you have to say but i genuinely think um
show any of these stories you're
concerned about to a doctor because
they're going to know so much more than
any of us when it comes to like certain
counter indications
right underlying conditions i mean you
hope that they will yeah well no no no
no no
no no
no no no no no one's on the doctor yeah
depends on what they're doing i was
asking a pediatrician about vaccinations
and
um
i had kind of a dodgy answer you got a
bad doctor
if you if you called a plumber and you
said that my my toilet's backed up and
he went oh your um
uh a bobo uh line must be birthed you'd
be like i think i don't think you know
what you're talking about i'm going to
call a different plumber i don't
understand why people have that that uh
like if if your doctor can't give you
legitimate answers like you need to find
one yeah i mean what i'd like to know is
i'm interested to know what the risks
are
you know they're talking about emergency
authorization for vaccinations for
children under 12.
and i'm saying like
is there a way to know what the risks
are is there a way to like are there
additional tests that you could run on
kids to make sure that they're not
susceptible to some of these
adverse reactions you know
uh and the answer was no
really that's that's the problem with
rushing vaccines out it doesn't seem
like i think i think it's an issue of
people taking their doctors their
medical their health for granted and
just assuming that because you've hired
someone they're good at their job that's
for sure dude the the human body is i
this has been on my mind a lot too the
greatest gift god has ever given us and
to abuse it is blasphemous and is
demonic it's a it's a form of possession
to abuse your body whether that's
obesity or
haphazardly injecting yourself with god
knows what it's it's
take it seriously i'm i'm literally not
worried about the vaccines you're
vaccinated i think the issue is people
need to do better when they're choosing
their their doctors the doctor my family
had was a family friend they they knew
him they trusted him he gave answered
all the questions helped uh
calm people down i think the issue is
probably a lot of people have bad
doctors and they're not virologists you
get a doctorate in virology you get a
doctorate in brain in neuro chemistry
you get a doctorate in philosophy you're
still a doctor well that doesn't mean
you know anything about yeah nothing
that would work well you're saying go
like libya saying she went to a
pediatrician and asked about viruses the
pediatrician's not educated in viruses
it's not a virologist so you're gonna
get you need to go to the right doctors
the people that actually know the stuff
and good luck finding them i guess you
need to go to health care practitioners
who are knowledgeable who have been
reading the modern literature and the
science and are going to give you a
legitimate honest opinion based on
everything that's going on not a
political opinion
let's read some more
ew says libby you should look at tulsa
oklahoma for the post-millennial tulsa
is a mid-major city cheap cost of living
good people great culture like a mini
austin and on the best uh one of the
best kept secrets in the red states come
down i'll happily host
what city was
tulsa tulsa oklahoma yeah nebraska's uh
pretty good isn't it i think so i
remember for a while all the good bands
were coming out of uh what omaha
nebraska wasn't like sleet or kenny from
omaha omaha nebraska wow she's great
yeah florida man says youtube just gave
me a strike for uploading rams video
medical misinformation they claim i'm
over the tyranny we the people need to
clean up dc i mean that's sf actually
but you know but i hear what you're
saying
i don't know man
this is the craziest thing because i'm i
don't understand how youtube enforces
its rules
i i genuinely think
it's like
purposefully vague and confusing
i have no idea
all i know is i do not want to uh assume
any liability for someone doing anything
dumb so talk to your doctor about what's
right for you
strikes are something else like you can
get strike struck in band or whatever
and we have other means we have the
podcast we got you know the website
but i don't give financial advice i
don't give medical advice you got to go
to a financial planner and a doctor so
leave me out of that stuff
alex on earth says was loki right in his
speech about kneeling being the natural
state of human you know uh when ian was
saying that i did want to do the loki
line he's like you know is this not
better your natural state humans
crave subjugation
i don't i don't i think he's over the
top but i think what you see is that
most people are willing to accept
kneeling before a tyrant if it means
they'll just get to go to their house
close the door and eat you know hot
pocket or something to the point where
we have social security cards now at
birth they don't even ask us if we want
them we just
you are registered are we born kneeling
wait chickens you get a social security
card at birth yeah you're assigned a
number at birth but you have to apply
for a social security card oh not the
card the number you get a number at
birth they didn't used to until like the
30s or something but you have to like
apply for it like i think you just don't
you just get a number you apply your kid
for it yeah i had to like go get it and
what if you don't do that i don't know
your kid doesn't exist reminds me of
rick and morty when he's playing roy and
they're like this guy's taking him off
the grid he doesn't have a social
security number
that's funny
all right you know what's weird about
security numbers i lost my social
security card at one point i had to get
anyone and i went to the social security
office to get it and they had someone
who was not my mother listed as my
mother and they they were like asking me
the emergency questions like oh and
who's your mother and i said and they
were like that's not your mother and i
was like uh she's standing right here
like she drove me down here
all right let's see
pretty weird laura wren says it's my
birthday and for my birthday i was
refused entry into my girl's icu because
of the new restrictions july 30th she
was crushed by a semi four hours away
another state we have a gofundme help
carol ann caroline recover not
everything is covered by insurance i'm
so sorry to hear that and i'm sorry to
hear about the whole situation best of
luck
that's uh gofundme carol ann recover
all right let's see we got here
we'll do a couple more here
richard cranium says with almost 30k
people watching let's hit that like
button that's right definitely
all right let's see blackrock beacon
says to all serving in the armed forces
look up dod directive 6200.2
use of investigational new drugs for
force health protection we need to start
doing foia requests to ensure all
protocols were properly followed
otherwise vax is an unlawful order
and i i'll stress to people uh the doj
has uh uh i think the supreme court's
ruled on this they can mandate vaccines
nationwide if they wanted to wow yeah
what i'm pretty sure yeah yeah i think
it was har meet dylan who also did a
thread saying like she has to let people
understand that like
jobs are allowed to mandate it from you
yeah
okay we'll just do a couple more
william j says libby looks like
elizabeth moss from the show handmaid's
tale great show very relevant to what's
going on today
you what people say that to me that's
funny
all right let's see we got
zane pv says if you're okay with
companies mandating employees get the
vaccine would you be okay with them
forcing women to take birth control
um
i guess the answer is yes if a company
says
we
i'm talking about small businesses mind
you like larger corporations with
heavier regulation and thousands of
employees are different i'm saying like
a small business if there's a guy who
makes pizzas and it's literally just him
in his kitchen and has to hire somebody
and he's like i don't want somebody
who's coming in here and doing you know
x y or z
then it's his choice
uh you know
within certain cert within reason so i
don't know it's a tough question i gotta
be honest maybe the answer to that one
is no and maybe it's not so much an
issue of principle it's an issue of
personal morals and that's an important
distinction as well i might say
something like i don't think businesses
should be forced but i also have an
issue with this kind of violation of
ethics and then it becomes a really this
is why i'm never going to be a
politician because i don't want to be
legislating law or writing up what
should or shouldn't be because someone's
going to say it's not fair if i have to
do x if this person doesn't have to do y
and then i'm just like bro i am not
going to be a king of anybody i think
human traffickers force girls to go on
birth control before they escort them
across the border because of the uh
yikes man this is what this is what ted
cruz was telling me the other day was uh
was it not just me it was at this
conference in houston uh but he was
saying that um
the human traffickers forced girls to be
on birth control because they are going
to get raped on the journey that's
messed up it's messed up yeah oh yeah i
talked to this other guy uh um
who was showing me the bracelets that
the human traffickers put on people when
they're crossing the border would be
like you know it'll say like mohair on
them and stuff just like
identifying who everybody is as to where
they're going to be uh like sold off to
and stuff
that's really a mess it's the people who
are
profiting from that are clearly the
massive international human trafficking
cartels well my friends thanks for
hanging out we're gonna go uh start
doing the members only segment so go to
timcast.com become a member and we'll
have the bonus segment coming up shortly
you can also subscribe to this channel
hit the like button leave us a good
review
and follow us at tim cast irl and you
can uh tim cast irl and you can follow
me personally at tim cast do you want to
shout anything out lydia oh yeah i'm
libby emmons i'm at the post millennial
every day and i'm at libbyes on twitter
thanks thanks for coming libby thanks uh
yeah follow me in crossland guys thanks
for coming
thank you so much for coming libby and i
just wanted to say too that part of what
we're doing with the culture is giving
some kind of alternative because i have
noticed that one thing conservatives
like to do is say this is bad bad bad
bet so what are you offering as a what
am i offering alternative no not youtube
or whatever i'm glad you guys are answer
that question yeah answer it
i'm writing a book actually on how to
make a conservative arts and culture
movement that's awesome perfect yeah you
know exactly what's up go to timcast.com
and we'll try we always try to get this
segment up by about 11 or so so we will
uh see you all then
you